I'm not gonna lie, I almost forgot I was streaming for a second.
I'm not gonna lie, I just thought I could do this for the whole time.
Hello and welcome back after so long to Eternal Darkness!
Oh my goodness, sorry.
I am extra sleepy today.
Mega sleepy.
I was planning on going a long time.
If I wake up, I will go a long time.
If I don't wake up, I'll just go for a medium time.
This isn't part one?
No.
Audio's loud?
I can't tell which one you hear.
Shouldn't be that loud.
Maybe I'm just quiet.
It's very loud!
It's showing up not even that loud on my side.
What the heck?
I'm quiet?
Is that...
Is that less quiet or less loud?
I'm doing experiments right now.
Wait, is it actually?
I think you guys hear double audio.
What about this?
So weird!
Okay, so like now it's quiet.
So that should be better.
I'm still learning.
This is why I play the OBS.
Instead of using a separate monitor.
Because I can control things better.
Being lovely as always.
Thank you!
Hello Minto!
Thank you for streaming at this time.
Thank you for being here at this time!
Thank you!
Okay, so that should be better.
Anyway, thank you guys.
Let's ignore that.
It's been a long time since I last played Eternal Darkness.
Like a long time.
Like...
A month at least.
And this game is already pretty wacky.
So I'm quite worried that I've forgotten how to play.
But also...
I can't remember where we left off.
You still play through OBS?
No!
That's...
Comprehens...
Listening comprehension!
I said this is why I like to play through OBS instead of a separate monitor.
Because I can control the audio better.
But because I'm playing through a monitor...
I can't control the audio as well!
Gosh!
I'm not playing through OBS!
Indiana Jones stage.
That's right!
Oh my gosh!
There was that guy that tried to kill me!
And then...
We ended.
Yes!
I remember!
You're...
You are Indiana Jones.
Yes!
I remember!
That guy tried to kill us!
Yes!
So you're playing through OBS...
STOP!
Stop it!
Stop!
I'm not playing through OBS!
This game belongs in a museum!
Oh my gosh!
Ever since I saw...
I went to the zoo in Japan.
And I saw like...
Thank you!
I saw like a regular goose.
You know, like a Canadian goose.
I saw it in the zoo.
And I was like, wow!
I see these like...
You know...
Just around town.
And so I was like...
Ever since...
Ever since I saw him...
I was like...
I was making fun of him in the zoo.
I was like, you belong in a museum.
And now I've been saying it for everything.
I'll see something and I'll be like, it belongs in a museum!
It's like my catchphrase right now.
Yippee!
A more EU compatible stream!
I just finished Milking Farm, the Minotaur story.
It was interesting, but it wasn't for me.
I kept going because I kept imagining Mint being like...
The whole time I was laughing so much though.
Actually, Matara and I talked about that in the last episode even.
I go into more detail.
It was so long ago.
I can't remember so much of it.
Minto, you look cuter today.
Maybe it's my brain at 1am.
Go to sleep!
That should be me.
I should be asleep right now.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired!
But that's okay.
Hopefully this game... Hopefully my sanity is restored.
With this.
So yes, we're Dr. Edwin Lindsey.
And we're in 1983 AD.
And we are basically Indiana Jones.
Basically.
I think.
So let's... I'm going to have to relearn how to do the combat.
But I have confidence.
Are you sure you want to load this game?
Yeah.
Here we go!
The darkness comes.
Oh my gosh.
Paragon, paragon, paragon.
There's a big secret in this chapter?
What do you mean by that?
Also, I can't hear it now.
It's so low.
I think maybe just the ambience in that other one was...
Okay.
Maybe that's better.
Sanity riz-stored.
Don't say that.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Using a...
Okay, we have a gun!
But we have shotgun shells, but no shotgun.
We have pistol ammo.
We are holding a pistol.
We do have a shotgun!
I'm a liar.
Equip with a shotgun.
And we have a knife.
We have our archaeologist brush.
We've got a torch.
Nice.
Sounds like double audio.
See?
I think there really is double audio.
Wait, so... hold on.
Experiment again.
If I do this, can you hear it?
Can you hear the audio if I... I'm so confused.
You can hear it.
See?
Oh my gosh.
I knew it this whole time.
But then why during Metal Gear you guys couldn't hear it?
I have no idea.
Everything is so confused for me.
Everything is... this whole setup is so confusing for me.
Just a thing with this game?
I don't think so.
But you can still hear it right now, right?
Too busy to watch.
So vodking.
Thanks for... dropping by though.
Thanks for the super chat!
Try...
Oh!
Ah!
Shut up!
It's kind of loud.
I'm so confused.
How do I get to my... magic?
So we got a shotgun.
That's how I aim.
I hope I don't die.
Examine.
Nice.
Let's just leave.
Can I run?
Oh gosh.
How do I run again?
Oh my gosh.
How do I do everything?
Lindsay cannot cast spells without the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Oh.
This is how I sneak?
This is how...
Ah!
That's how I shoot?
Oh my gosh.
Scared the heck out of me.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Maybe there's like a... hold on.
Controller.
Okay.
Here we go.
Tome of Tidal Drop.
Okay.
Here we go.
L is to run.
Move character.
Access book.
Sneak.
Quick spell.
Attack.
To target an enemy.
Okay.
That's what I was doing.
I was holding the R button.
And then release to hold.
Okay.
All right.
Quick spell two through five.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
Actually try to leave.
It's funny.
Okay.
Let's try.
Run.
Lindsay has no intention of leaving the temple yet.
He is determined to get to the artifact before Augustine does.
No one ever crosses Edwin Lindsay.
Yeah.
Screw that guy.
So we...
Yeah.
That guy literally tried to kill us.
And so we're gonna kick his butt.
I remember this so much.
Statue of a seated goddess.
A bronze bracelet is worn on her wrist.
But where her neck should bear jewelry, there are only worn grooves and flecks of bronze dust.
Sounds so pompous.
I mean, wouldn't you be?
This guy is Edwiana Jones.
Okay.
I think there's only that one way we can go.
Ooh.
I'm tired.
My stamina.
All right.
Let's go.
He has such a power walk.
I'm nervous though.
Oh no.
Oh.
Time to get a tome, everybody.
Step on your faces.
Step on you.
Elia.
Oh.
I don't even do that.
Who are you?
Pius Augustus.
Oh no.
Pius.
It's all the people that had the book.
The tome.
Karim.
Yes.
I've never even met him.
I've never even noticed this before.
Anthony.
Yeah.
This guy was our simp.
Look it.
He's just like staring at the people on the ground.
He's like, you good?
Oh my gosh.
Here's best character over here.
Yeah.
Roivas.
All my homies love Roivas.
It's a little loud.
I don't know.
It's a little...
Can you hear me?
Can you guys shut up for two seconds?
Cradled in what appears to be a leathery hand lies a mysterious book.
Shh.
It is bound in human skin.
And intricately decorated with shrunken bones.
It beckons in yours to be possessed.
But doesn't claim it.
Yes.
Shut up.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
So now we have our Tome of Eternal Darkness.
We're going to check this thing.
This is the Tome of Eternal Darkness, where experience, spells, and enchanted items can be stored.
Yes.
Spell list.
Okay.
We have, we have enchant an item, recover, reveal invisible.
This is how we sound when you're five seconds late.
I believe it.
If you're a weapon that the devs need.
There's mad descriptions for all the weapons.
Pretty detailed.
Wait, like...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I want to see.
Wait.
Check.
Since 1907, this weapon has been a trusted sidearm to U.S.
armed forces.
Through two world wars, Korea and Vietnam, the Colt M1911 automatic pistol has proven itself to be a reliable firearm with good quality.
And stopping power.
Nice.
The unusual L-shape of the Kukri gives the weapon a significant advantage in close quarters.
Close quarters combat.
The combination of a cutting edge on the inside curve of the blade and heavy weight of the blade tip gives the Kukri immense chopping power.
The Kukri?
Kukri?
The L weapon.
Um, yeah, L.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm going to keep checking things.
I just want to make sure I know what I'm doing.
Quick spell number one.
And quick spell...
Okay.
Y.
Sneak.
Attack.
Reload is Z.
Okay.
And then to target is R.
Release and hold.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm scared!
Sorry my voice is also a little rasper today.
Okay.
Here I go.
Ah!
Here I go!
Here I leave!
They didn't even give me a seconds notice.
I'm sorry.
Without just being like, by the way, there's demons in here.
What's my spell number one?
Hold on.
Spell... oh wait, quick spell.
Oh, I don't have one on why.
Enchant item, recover...
So there is recover sanity.
Which is the bottom one.
Recover health is the left one.
And then recover magic is the...
right one.
Okay, okay, it's all coming back to me.
I believe.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
Spend magic to recover magic.
Yeah, pretty much.
Recover magic is useless though.
Yeah, probably won't use that one.
But, I want to enchant my gun.
Can I enchant my gun?
Yippee!
Wasn't there...
Though, wasn't there ways to like enchant different colors?
Depending on the guy.
Actually, now I think about it.
Hold on.
No, not check.
Well, yeah.
No, hold on.
Yeah, there was.
Wasn't there?
Yes!
Oh my gosh, but I only have the one!
I only have the one as a quick spell.
I think those guys just glowed green.
I think those guys just glowed green when I walked in.
Enchant gun equals magic missile.
Yeah!
And so, I'm gonna redo it.
Wait, so green beats...
Wait, is it green beats green?
Or is it...
Wait, red?
I should be red?
Okay, gotta use the weakness.
Okay.
Sorry.
It's all coming back to me.
Slowly.
But surely.
Okay.
So, Pokemon.
It's Pokemon.
Sorry, my mind was...
My mind was blue archive.
My mind was blue archive, not Pokemon.
Okay.
We're good.
Let's go.
Oh my God!
Finish him!
I think I'm insane.
Insane?
Then... Yes, that does use ammo.
Oh, I think my head was blocking it.
But to finish them, it does use ammo.
So, we're gonna have to be careful.
What was reload again?
Reload is Z.
All right.
Seven shots.
We're examining.
Um...
Oh.
Uh...
Sun...
Hi.
Oh.
This carving represents the growth of the human race.
My bad magic boomstick.
It's rise to intelligence and the development of society.
It foreshadows the decline of humanity.
This is humanity's dusk.
Okay.
Okey-dokey.
Anything over here?
I'm just staring at that guy.
I'm like, don't wake up.
Don't get up.
Don't wake up.
What is that?
Oh.
I've...
It's these things.
Oh.
I...
Oh!
Let's go!
Okay.
Easy.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Maybe I just run through this.
Ha!
But those things...
I sneak past them, I think.
Oh gosh.
I keep clicking stuff.
I don't know what I'm clicking.
Don't walk on that.
Don't do it.
Ah!
I just walked on it.
We're probably okay.
Where does this go?
No where?
Okay.
What about here?
Oh!
Displayed upon the pedestal is a metal bracelet.
Oh...
I got a metal bracelet.
Let's see.
I clicked on something else!
Oh my gosh.
I'm really bad at this.
Don't click on those.
Yeah, yeah, nice, nice.
Wait, is this a... no.
Okay, that's a wall.
Examine.
A spiderweb.
The corner is shrouded with dense cobwebs, casting it into shadow, perhaps even hiding something.
I have... a torch!
Yes!
Okay.
What is it hiding?
Oh, the brush!
I'm an archaeologist, everybody.
Oh my gosh!
What the hell?
How could that be revealed that my torch could not show?
Excuse me!
Oh no, minus one.
My joke wasn't funny.
Hidden behind the strings of cobwebs is a carved stone tablet.
I got a magical codex!
Okay, attach my gun.
Where's my gun?
Maybe I want... actually...
Can't the torch though... isn't the torch kind of OP?
Like, can't I just burn these guys?
Isn't it kind of awesome?
Maybe I should use this instead, not waste my bullets.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh, maybe I should have my bullets.
Let's...
And it was green, so maybe I...
And cast...
I cast...
Enchant item!
Friend-shaped?
I don't know about that.
It's now enchanted!
Okay.
Let's go.
What do you mean you have a barrier?
What is this?
He's leaving me alone though.
Maybe I just...
A bronze necklace.
Just gonna take that.
Kinda cool.
Oh sorry, I know you guys are like blocking most of him.
And so me too.
I like just...
Oh, there's another necklace!
Behind him.
There you go.
I think I need that though.
He's trapped.
Do I have a spell?
I don't know why I would want to release him, but...
Reveal it...
That...
He belongs in a zoo.
He belongs in a museum.
Where's him?
If I go...
If I go over here...
What if I like...
Kind of walk into his aura?
I'm scared.
It's kind of nice being able to see him like so close like this, you know?
He's kind of a mouth breather, but that's okay.
Be brave.
Okay.
Ow!
Oh!
Okay.
I got it.
Um...
Maybe I have to go back then.
Maybe I do put it on the...
Oh my gosh.
Be careful.
Please, sir.
I wish I could see for...
Forward.
I wish I could see forward.
I wish I could see in front of me if there's any of those crit...
Little critters.
You know?
I can't even hug him.
It's fine.
He probably...
Doesn't...
Would prefer...
Rather not to.
You know?
I don't think I can avoid this one.
Um...
Okay.
Okay, Indy.
Big step.
Big step now, okay?
Big...
One big...
Well, you could see it right there.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
What's up?
Hold on.
I'm gonna equip the torch real quick.
Yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
All right, Indy.
I don't remember.
What's his...
Edwin.
All right, Edwin.
Okay!
Professional.
Don't wake up.
Oh, bye.
We're gonna go put that necklace on.
See if it does anything.
I think it's gonna open one of these doors, right?
Yes!
Oh!
We can go one of two ways.
We can go...
Which way should we go?
We can go to this area.
How mysterious.
Or we can go back to our friend.
Let's see.
I know there's gonna be guys right here.
Oh.
Ah!
Examine.
This particular depiction represents the birth of the human race within the universe.
This is humanity.
Humanity is dawn.
Okay.
I'm gonna take...
I'm gonna loot.
I'm gonna take that.
Stone statue of the Naga.
Oh!
A snake-headed demon.
Stands guard in the corner of the room.
A raised platform stands before it with a bracelet.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna take that.
Yep.
That's fine now.
Oh!
No!
I shouldn't have taken that.
Wait!
I shouldn't have...
Okay!
I'm sorry!
Wait!
Can I fool it?
Into...
Can I take...
Maybe I can...
Maybe I can trick the ghost.
Hold on.
This guy is so unfazed.
Take this ugly one.
Yeah.
Idiot.
Take that!
Oh.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Combat ready.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Okay.
Let's not activate the traps.
Just big step.
Right here.
There you go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
He's gonna wake up.
Oh, I see him right there.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, come here.
Come here.
Come here, dummy!
No!
You activated the trap, you asshole!
Ouch!
Okay, I'm leaving.
What a jerk!
It's fine.
He's dead.
Okay.
Is he activated?
What do you think?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we just have to get them before they get us.
Okay.
I see those two.
I don't think...
Okay, here we go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Is that a pressure plate?
Just die!
I can't tell.
Out it is!
It's fine.
Um...
Oh.
Can you...
Can you get this guy?
Can you take him out?
Oh.
I got a rune.
Sapphire!
The torch is kind of OP.
Anyway.
Um...
What's this?
This design depicts humanity's fall into decadence, corruption, and ultimately oblivion.
This is humanity's night.
Our time.
Whoa.
This is humanity's night.
Okay.
Good night!
Humanity's night.
Whoa.
The ceiling is so pretty, even.
Okay.
Hello?
Can I light these?
Oh, examine.
Yeah, yeah.
I can, actually.
A collection of unlit candles.
Okay.
I remember the candles.
So, because this is night, we keep them off.
Oh.
I wish I could see in front of me.
These camera angles are killing me, man.
Ah!
What the hell?
I didn't even touch anything!
Oh, my health.
Okay.
Let's, uh...
Let's use a spell.
Um...
Recover.
Oh, I didn't even notice I was getting a little tilted.
I didn't even notice.
I think was I naturally tilted?
I actually kind of play like this sometimes.
How is my sanity, though?
Oh wait, that was my sanity, not my health.
Just kidding.
But still.
Okay, sanity is green.
Magic is blue.
Health is red.
Unduchess your angle.
There was definitely a guy in there, though.
But then also the trap.
Oh, I think he stepped on it.
He's the one that stepped on it and he's activating everything.
Come over here.
Come on.
Come on, just step on it.
Just make your way over.
Wait, did he die?
You think he got chopped up?
He just died.
I heard him go...
Okay, awesome.
Watch out for traps.
Watch out for...
Oh, that's one, right?
I can't tell if there's any other guy in here, though.
Don't step on it.
Okay, good, good, good.
I don't hear anybody awakening.
I only hear sounds of...
Awaken with the sounds of nature.
Careful.
Okay.
Awesome.
Yippee!
Wow.
Hiding in the shadows, a statue watches over the room.
A brief inspection reveals flecks of silver metal marring the statue's wrists and neck, possibly indicating that a decoration used to be there.
We have one of them!
We have the silver bracelet.
Okay.
We just gotta get the necklace which was behind our little friend.
Is this the way?
Okay, not yet.
This looks like a door.
Closed door lying in shadow seals off the passageway.
And this...
We can...
use this.
Shhh!
What's this?
A tattered scroll.
Dispel magic.
So we're gonna dispel the magic.
Ah ha, so we're gonna dispel the thing that's holding him captive.
Ah ha!
Ha ha ha.
For every magic, there's a counter.
I have no idea what's going on.
That which is bound is unbound.
Be warned that a more powerful magic than this will endure its ravages.
Free the friend.
Release friend-shaped dude.
Dorito man shall be born.
Nethlek and Radgormor.
Oh god.
Do I have those?
I'll have that one.
I'll have a mystery.
We'll... we'll figure it out.
Easy.
I bet there's going to be...
There's going to be a guy here that wakes up though.
And he's going to activate a button.
He's going to activate something.
There's going to be a guy here.
Oh, there's buttons there.
I'm scared.
Oh my gosh, giant button?
Wait, this is a button, right?
I don't think this is avoidable.
We went in one big circle!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh, well, that makes it really easy to get back to then.
He really does kind of look like a green Dorito, doesn't he?
Well, now.
Maybe.
I don't remember how to do this.
Area?
Okay.
Oh...
Choose alignment, then choose runes.
So, if it's... if I'm trying to dispel green, would I use green, or would I use red?
Is it still... Pokmon rules here, or?
Oh, wait.
New spell.
Okay.
It was this one.
This is the second one.
And... let's do the mysterious one.
Ah!
We did it!
Always Pokemon rules.
Okay, always Pokemon rules.
Aha!
Okay.
Now we're gonna do some other stuff real quick.
Let's enchant our shotgun.
Very cool.
Save.
Yeah, that would be a great idea too, wouldn't it?
Let's save the game.
Let's leave the room.
Save... What do you mean it's... What do you mean?
Is it that... Ah!
Let's leave the room.
What the...
Because of the traps.
ViviCore, thanks for the gift.
Oh,
I just enchanted that even.
I'm gonna have to re-enchant it.
Okay, I do wanna save though.
So we'll go back to the main room.
It's okay.
This one is easier than...
The other one, I think.
To get through.
Yeah, yeah.
See, see, see?
Easy peasy.
The darkness is coming?
What do you mean by that?
Okay, this room has to be safe.
Please.
Thank you.
Yes, save and continue.
Okay.
Alright.
Is it this bozo right here?
Well, he's not getting up.
Just leave him.
Let him... Let him rest.
Let him sleep, you know?
Okay.
Okay, good steps.
Good steps.
Soup.
Thank you!
Where's the suspense if Indiana Jones never sets off a trap?
The suspense is right here.
It's in... column A, column B.
Oh, it is still enchanted.
Awesome.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
This room is tiny.
So I'm really... I'm kind of nervous.
This room is really small.
Like how am I supposed to... how am I supposed to avoid this guy, you know?
Get his ass!
I think we did it.
Yeah!
I love the shotgun.
Um, finish him!
Sanity restored, baby.
Shotgun is awesome.
The torch is awesome.
It's just, uh...
Silver necklace is draped around the center.
I'm just gonna take that.
Uh, yoink!
I saw something!
Yeah, though.
Yeah, see?
There's blood!
I saw this... yeah!
Is this from my sanity being low?
The walls are bleeding.
What's this?
This particular depiction represents the prosperity of humanity and its domination over the world.
This is humanity's day.
It's my day!
Oh!
The walls are still bleeding.
Maybe I should do a restore on me?
Are we okay?
It's not going away!
I think the walls are just, um...
like that.
It's just normal.
Okay, good.
Wait.
This big button, I can't avoid it.
Okay, uh...
Argh!
AHH!
OK.
I'll see you later!
Helpitter!
Hahahaha!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, no.
No, no, no!
Here it goes.
Ha!
It's mine!
Oh wait.
I bestow upon thee silver necklace.
Nice moves, thanks.
Thanks very much.
Alright, ikimashou.
Don't talk to me.
Anybody else?
Anybody else want this?
The music is a little dramatic.
A little freaky.
I hear someone walking.
I hear them.
You.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa!
Green!
What is this place?
Oh my gosh, I really feel like I'm in Indiana Jones right now.
Yippee!
It's the one-hit kill.
It's so funny.
My sanity is getting lower and lower.
Oh, what is that?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, what are you?
What is that thing?
I can hear my heartbeat in my ears, which is crazy because I'm a ghost.
Do you think I can one-hit kill this guy?
No.
I think I'm gonna use this.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, ow!
It's the thing we fought at the beginning!
That's right.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Um...
It's the thing we fought at the beginning.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
No, no, no, no, stop stealing.
Stop stealing from me.
Insanity.
Hold on.
Okay.
I shoot it, and then I have to shoot it again.
We have magic this time.
Does that even help?
Let's, um, enchant it, then.
Yeah, we gotta wait for him.
I think he gets close to me, and then I can...
Yeah, he, like, flashes me.
Right?
I gotta let him get close.
And I gotta get the head.
What?
What's happening?
What are you doing?
Ah!
He's really...
Wait, what's going on?
Oh, he's summoning things?
No way.
Oh my gosh.
Um, let's get my torch out.
Yeah, you freak.
Okay.
He's really draining my sanity here.
There we go.
Finish him.
And we are not a Dutch angle anymore.
But I will, um...
I'm glad I pressed the right one.
Let's, uh, reload.
I cry every time she uses shotgun shell to finish anatomy.
You know what I mean?
Not gonna lie, I do too.
But...
Um...
I guess I could just switch to my pistol, huh?
Or, I could just, like...
Can't you, like, kick him too?
Kick him while they're down?
Whoa.
Hey, wait, what?
It was green earlier.
What happened?
Why is it not green anymore?
It's more badass with the shotgun.
This is more wasteful for sure.
Misty.
It's very, um, Silent Hill in here.
Let's see if I can save.
Oh, it will let me.
It will let me.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh!
Ow!
Hey.
It's just how easy...
I even saw it.
As soon as I stepped on it, I saw it.
All is well.
Okay.
Careful.
Wait, are these all steps?
I can't tell.
It's a little dicey here.
Oh my gosh.
I can't tell at all.
Oh gosh.
Well, I guess we're about to find out!
Ah!
Oh, we surely found out.
What's that sound?
What's making all that noise?
Who's working here?
Oh, I don't know if I like this guy.
A statue of carved granite depicting a ceremonial temple guard.
It appears to be keeping watch on the seated goddess in the corner of the room.
Okay, perv.
A statue of an unknown goddess seated in a classical pose.
She appears to be carrying something valuable.
Oh, I see.
Yeah...
And...
Sounds like something I need to grab.
What did I just do?
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm the goddess in the corner of the room.
Yeah!
Oh, I see.
Okay.
We need to put something here.
Do I have to?
Do I have to grab anything?
Nothing.
It's because you called him a perv.
He's like, oh, you're calling a perv.
Okay.
And then this looks like a door.
Yeah, yeah.
We get it.
There's a panel recessed slightly into the wall.
It looks like it can be pressed.
Should Lindsay press the panel?
Sure.
Okay.
Press the panel, Lindsay.
Oh.
I was expecting something to happen.
Oh, it's timed?
Wait.
Huh?
What is going...
Okay.
So, that does something.
And it's also timed.
Okay.
Let's go into the next room.
Oh, no.
How am I supposed to get around this one?
It's just a whole block.
How are you supposed to get around it?
Sneak?
Sneak over it?
You don't.
That's the fun.
Okay.
Big step, Lindsay.
Ah!
Oh.
Poisonous gas, Lindsay.
Poisonous gas.
Okay.
I think we have to go the other way.
Right?
Because I can't get out of here.
Because it'll probably be another loop.
And once we activate the poisonous gas, we just run through here, you know?
Probably.
Most likely.
That is probably the case.
Okay.
Easy.
Easy, Lindsay.
Careful steps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
That guy is definitely going to reanimate and probably ruin our time.
He's just not going to make it.
Oh, wait.
There's another steppy there.
Oh, my gosh.
It's another giant steppy.
You are just going to ruin our time, aren't you?
There he is.
There he goes.
Come on.
Just do it.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want to recover my sanity.
Okay.
Okay, you guys have to tell me to stop recovering my sanity so much.
Because I also...
I want to see the craziness that happens, you know what I mean?
So this one's unavoidable, so...
Okay, let's just go for it.
If you get too low health, your movement speed slows.
If that happens in a gas room, you're pretty much dead.
Rushing without healing got me killed twice.
Thank you, Rhett, for the warning.
Oh gosh,
I can't see.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, he's crawling?
Oh, okay.
Okay, see, now I can...
Here, I'll equip this and I'll finish him.
Right?
Finish him!
Yeah!
What was...
Ooh, my health is at real bad.
Hold on, I gotta get to my quick spells.
Okay, recover health was this one.
Oh my gosh, it does not recover a lot.
And we lost a lot...
I think it's just moving around is what gets us to gain more magic.
Pretty sure.
So, if we just kinda walk...
We'll just do a little dance here and there.
And then, we also need to do the dispel magic cast.
What was it?
Sorry.
It's red, so it should be blue.
Okay, I was right.
Oh!
Wait, what is this?
How did it even...
What...
What is this?
What is that?
Okay.
Cool.
I haven't even seen that.
Okay.
We're just gonna run around the room a little bit.
Actually, we're gonna be an archaeologist for two seconds.
Secret chamber?
Is that the important secret you guys were talking about?
A dirt-encrusted necklace is hidden behind the cobwebs.
Found a necklace!
Okay.
Oh, man.
Can you imagine being, like, one of the poorest people in the world?
One of the people that gets, like, the ugly necklace?
This has the panel!
Okay.
I don't understand what it does.
And then it...
It's very fast, so it's not like I can get to the other rooms.
I feel, you know?
Okay, my magic is getting there.
Okay.
Now for our thicker necklace.
Hopefully that's better, right?
Yeah, who's the poor sap that got gifted this necklace?
Everybody else gets diamonds.
You know, someone's getting the metal bracelet.
Someone's getting the... whatever this...
It just says necklace.
It doesn't even say what it's made out of.
Oh great, I got a necklace made out of gravel!
Thanks.
Good.
Check.
Yeah, what does it say?
This necklace is encrusted with cysts of corroded metal upon its surface.
It's difficult to tell what it looks like.
Perhaps it can be cleaned somehow.
I'm trying to clean it?
Okay.
I see that guy down there.
But I also see this right here.
Is this a... is this poison?
Here he comes!
He's gonna activate every trap on the way!
Maybe he'll die.
Oh my gosh.
Die.
Will we get lucky?
Activate that trap.
We did not get lucky.
His timing is impeccable.
If he can do it, I can do it.
Probably.
See ya!
Just a single...
Okay.
Alright.
Is this a... is this a booby trap?
Is this a booby trap?
Oh no no no!
Oh shoot!
Just run!
Oh.
Hello.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Everything is bad, you guys.
Everything is bad.
Where's my shotgun?
Oh here it is.
But I have to...
I can't tell if I missed or...
If he just is immune.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
That's right.
And uh... you.
Oh my god!
No!
This is messed up!
Please turn around.
Oh my gosh.
I'm stuck on the wall.
Please!
Turn around!
How can I like, chop off their arms?
Idiot!
What the fuck?
This is so messed up!
Oh no no no no no!
Wait wait wait wait wait!
Um...
Oh no!
Uh...
Wait how...
Did you forget?
Yes I did.
Um...
I did forget.
The red guy's regen?
Okay...
So...
Let's um...
And then...
Enchant...
Blue...
I don't wanna waste my bullets.
Nice.
And you're back at the end.
Ow!
Ow Ow.
Finish him!
Where?
Oh...
Finish him?
Finish him.
Oh come on!
He's not letting me finish him!
Um...
Uh...
I used my gun...
Finish him!
Finish.
Finish him.
Oh, he's gone.
Just kidding.
Okay, well...
I guess it's fine.
Whatever.
Whatever!
Where is this though?
I don't remember seeing this at all!
This little... whatever area.
Where is that?
And then another thing to push.
What a silly game.
A face!
What did I just...
What was that?
Oh.
Okay.
It just returned.
That's all that was.
Yeah, the timer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
How's my health doing?
Let's heal again.
In fact, I'm gonna heal twice.
Nice!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay.
Onwards, I guess?
I hate these angles, man.
They're so rude.
Okay.
Don't do it.
Yeah, I got you before you could even step there.
Bozo.
Oh no, there's like two more down there.
Yeah, idiot.
Oh.
Hiding in the shadows, the statue watches over the room.
Gold flecks of metal mar the statue's wrist and neck.
Possibly indicating that some kind of adornment used to be there.
Okay, we know where the gold bracelet is.
I forgot about my pre-super chat.
Thanks!
Thanks for three months!
You're awesome, Minto.
Thank you!
Being afraid of angles is a very Lovecraft thing.
Is it really?
I know this game is very inspired, right?
So...
The necklace is perhaps...
This is perhaps a gold necklace.
But it said metal.
Corroded metal.
So maybe...
I don't know.
If we clean it, who knows?
Paragon, paragon, paragon, paragon.
So true.
So true, bestie.
Paragon.
Gold is a metal.
Okay, but it needs to be...
You know, some things just say metal.
They should say gold metal.
What did you say?
Did you click something?
Did you press something?
What was that?
I'm just gonna keep going.
Wait, actually...
I wanted to die first.
Yeah, there we go.
Welcome to the membership, thank you.
Alright.
Anybody else?
That's it?
Wow, that's a lot.
That's it!
Torch is so OP.
I know, I'm obsessed with it.
You can't finish them with it!
I guess if I like, did this...
That... oh.
I was too slow.
But it's just so OP, right?
Push!
Still
don't know what this is supposed to do.
I'm just pushing all of them.
What is this?
There is a small base in...
or font?
Situated beneath the statue.
Besides that...
Oh, besides that, an orb-shaped button sits on a panel of stone.
Should Lindsey push the button?
Hold on, Lindsey.
Lindsey, give me a second.
Lindsey, Lindsey, we're gonna do this spell first.
Screen.
The orb!
Oh!
Did you see that?
My camera just tilted.
Okay, hold on though.
Maybe I just passed it and never saw it.
Now we're back to Dutch Angling.
It was definitely in one of the hallways.
Just need to find that place now.
Is it down here?
Have I been through here?
I don't know where I've...
Cotton Eye Joe, where did you come from?
Where did you go?
That's me right now.
So I'm in here.
Wait!
See?
There's that...
There's a door right there.
There's like a little entrance.
Maybe that?
Maybe it's that one?
This is...
This is the next hallway?
Hold on, let's see which one this is.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Should I press the button first though?
Lindsay!
Should Lindsay push the button?
No.
I wanna go see first.
Wait, that was for the necklace?
You think so?
Oh, maybe...
Oh, I think you're right.
No!
Wait!
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Hear me out.
Is there a way to...
Zoom in?
C-stick.
See?
There!
I think that's it right there.
I think we were in the right hallway before.
Why is it...
Why is it inverted all of a sudden?
Yeah, I think it's that one.
I think it's that one instead.
Ha ha ha!
Okay, we go back.
Love how calm he is through all of this.
He walks with such like...
Certainty.
With such like...
Purpose, you know?
So maybe I should push the button.
Is there no ammo supply in the game?
I don't think so.
And in fact...
Thanks for bringing that up.
Because...
I would like to reload before we...
Encounter anything else, you know?
So let's reload this gun!
Let's reload...
This gun!
Okay!
Yes!
And let's save.
Okay!
Reload the torch.
So true.
I guess I'll push it.
I'm scared.
Oh!
It's just water!
Oh, it's...
Water.
Ha ha ha!
The water smells like a strong acid.
Strong enough to dissolve metal or flesh.
If Lindsay isn't careful.
Oh!
No, no, no!
Wait, wait, wait!
Lindsay!
Push the button.
Yes!
And...
Clean!
Oh!
Lindsay has found a gold necklace!
I don't know if we should touch that like so immediately.
With our bare hands.
Right after it like kind of soaked in the acid.
But you know, whatever.
I was ready to drink it.
Resplendent with glowing gems.
Wow.
Resplendent.
So in here.
Okay.
Let's do our best not to activate anything.
Careful.
Oh.
This one is kind of unavoidable.
I think.
Um.
Right.
Anyway.
This!
So, no.
We haven't been in here before then.
Oh.
Okay.
Look at all them skellies.
There appears to be a hole in the wall.
It is large enough for a small dog to pass through.
Ruff!
I don't have that.
Wait.
What am I supposed to do?
Um.
Just break it down, Lindsey!
Break it down!
Break it down, Lindsey!
Chat, why did you do that?
I got that dog in me.
There's a spell called Summon Trapper that you can send a creature in there.
Get it later in this chapter.
Oh.
Another hot dog.
Okay.
So, we need to go back to that one room.
Um.
I think it's this one, isn't it?
Yes.
Guys, if we still...
I still am not sure what to do with this.
What do...
Is there anything I can put here, or...?
Oh.
Spell 9?
Whatever it is?
Keep a summon.
I don't have a summon.
What do you mean a summon?
I don't have one.
I don't think I got any new runes.
Oh wait!
Summon!
I think we have to summon...
item?
Summon area?
I don't know how to tell you this, but you medically got that dog in you.
But you don't have the rune.
I just have...
I have this.
I don't know if it counts.
Does it?
I'm just gonna summon...
No, it doesn't count.
How do I...
What's it called?
Tear.
Where did we get this one?
Wait, this is the one that we...
Didn't we find this like behind a cobweb or something?
So if I...
New spell.
Okay, hold on.
Tear.
Yeah, it doesn't even show up.
Yeah, the negative one.
Oh...
How...
How do I turn it from a slab into a rune?
How do I turn it from that into a rune?
I got the codec, yeah.
Gotta find where the rune is.
The codec explains what it is.
The rune is to use it.
Like the codec gives it...
It gives the name and what it does.
Got it.
Got it, got it, got it, got it.
Okay, where...
Okay.
We are...
Here.
Oh, let's see.
Okay.
Where have...
Okay, we've been through all these rooms.
Is there...
What's...
So yeah, Z button is current.
So...
Where we're at.
X...
Okay, there's no more down.
Is it up?
Stairs?
Enemies have a rune floating inside them.
Did I miss...
A guy?
You can solve the bracelet puzzle room you're in right now.
How though?
If I can't summon something.
Unless it's with this.
Step on the pad and run for the bracelet.
We could try.
Grab it!
Oh.
Maybe we actually can.
I thought it was gonna be way faster.
I got a gold bracelet!
Yay!
Oh.
Hope he doesn't realize.
Okay.
I think we're good.
There's a level below this.
Oh, it's not showing it when I press X.
Like, down floor.
So, we must find it, I suppose?
I...
Suppose?
It keeps looking...
Oh my gosh.
I keep seeing, like, right here.
And thinking that it's an entrance.
Like, a doorway.
It might be.
I can't tell.
Okay.
Who was it that needed the...
The stuff?
Where was it?
Which room was it?
There's so many.
Probably opens up.
Yeah.
Probably.
The right hallway?
Okay.
Let's see.
This one activates the...
This activates the...
The...
What's that word?
The poison gas.
So, I don't know if I wanna go through this.
Run, Lindsey!
Run!
Lindsey.
We're in trouble, Lindsey.
Lindsey, we're in trouble.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh my gosh.
Not this room.
Are we okay?
We're fine.
Sorry, I know I keep opening.
Okay, so this is...
We're potentially...
So this is where we got the...
The...
The necklace.
Oh, wait!
It's right here!
Yes!
Okay, okay.
You'll get... this?
Since the game doesn't tell you and you can only read in a guidebook, the panel disabled traps for 30 seconds.
Right!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I was like... I was feeling like I was really missing something.
Thank you!
This game is wild.
Why don't they tell you?
Remember me, Alex.
How can I forget you, Grandpa?
Oh my gosh, I forgot we were a girl.
You always meant the most to me.
Ever since...
Ever since my parents died.
Yes.
Ever since they were killed.
You've been my little girl.
Grandpa.
Yes.
My little girl.
Okay, I was about to say that, but I didn't think he would say that.
This can't be happening.
You good?
I want to save here, but it probably won't let me because of the traps.
Now it definitely won't let me.
Because of all the crazy people in here.
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, I get... that's so cool.
There's a lot of guys down here, though.
Oh, they're all regenerative.
Oh, they're all red monsters.
No!
That's kind of lame.
Don't like that.
I hear something coming up.
Something's really squelching in my ear.
Two and a half hours of my time from becoming a geriatric.
What does that mean?
Let's...
What do I... Okay.
For the big guy downstairs, we're definitely going to want to use the shotgun.
But...
What do I want to use for the other guys?
Maybe just the...
Maybe we just slice and dice them?
Maybe?
Oh, birthday!
Happy early birthday!
Handgun for the guys.
Oh my gosh, it gets so dark.
It gets so dark.
I don't like that.
I don't like it.
Blue.
On my gun.
My item is now enchanted.
Oh, we're slightly tilted again.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, no, no.
Reload!
Uh...
Why aren't you reloading, you idiot?
What's taking him so long?
It wasn't reloading!
I was holding down Z, but he wasn't reloading!
Well, that's not good.
Okay.
Come on, reload.
I don't think I can walk and reload.
I think that's the issue.
Okay, we're just going to have to slice and dice...
We're just going to have to slice and dice them.
Finish him!
Oh...
Anybody else coming up here?
What a
jerk!
How's my health?
Okay, we're good on health.
Time to go.
I can't tell if I'm aiming at him or not.
Oh my gosh!
Ouch!
Are you aiming?
Are you hitting him?
Is he going to come up here?
Oh my god.
I think that did it.
Nice!
Finish him!
Oh, little whack!
He just goes...
Yippee!
Now can we save?
Okay, before we save though, I'm going to equip and I'm going to reload.
Slowpoke.
I thought you could run and reload at the same time.
Clearly Lindsey is not the brightest bunch.
Okay, there we go.
Little flick of the wrist.
Yeah, exactly.
Oop.
That means the room is safe.
Oh, let's put our...
One thing about this game...
I think my only gripe about the game...
Not only, but you know, a bigger gripe about the game is...
So much going into the menu.
You know?
Ah,
what's that?
Yeah, it kinda like takes you out of the game.
I am a little bit, you know, but I'm pretty menu-centric game.
It is very menu-centric.
These are like even more ancient traps.
Anything down here?
I don't mind the menus too much.
Let's go.
I'm glad then.
I think I don't mind it so much but...
What the hell?
Lindsay, are you okay?
Lindsay, are you alright?
Are you alright, friend?
Are you alright, buddy?
Okay, this one, I don't know if we can get past.
Lindsay, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, buddy?
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
Oh.
There's a lot of guys here.
Ah!
Run!
Run, run!
Yeah!
Run, run, run!
Oh!
Oh.
Run!
I love the torch!
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, I just noticed the thing in the middle.
Hardcore.
What about this guy?
He's not gonna wake up?
Yeah!
It's hard.
He's hiding something.
We got another stone slab.
It's a magical codex!
Magical.
This thing is...
Oh my god, this thing is so metal.
Wow, look at that.
Also, you just think, why are these like...
Why are these torches lit, you know?
What the hell?
I'm gonna go in there a little bit.
Okay!
Oh, I know that guy!
That's just like...
Oh!
Yeah, that's...
Oh, yeah!
That's Jeff!
Jeff the God.
Oh, I know that guy.
My creator...
Oh, there's a guy here.
There's like a meteor and everything.
What is going on?
This thing is so... Oh, look at all of them bowing before him!
This creature is really just like some prehistoric something or other crawled out from the ocean.
And they're like, whoa!
We love you, Jeff!
Paragon.
Manterbok.
Jeff.
I hate when it pops.
I came in through that way, so we're going this way.
Can I save?
Sorry, I know I'm save scumming.
Oh, we cannot.
I think it's this guy's fault.
It's this bozo's fault right here.
He won't even wake up, but he says it's too dangerous.
The darkness is coming!
Anybody here?
We're fine.
I almost missed these ones.
Shuffle.
Do the Lindsay shuffle.
Your human tongues cannot pronounce my name, so you can call me Jeff.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
I hate.
I have a big hatred.
I don't know.
I think they're going to hit me.
I don't think I'm going to...
My items are now enchanted!
Uh, aim.
Oh my gosh, run.
Run!
Who's crying?
My baby is crying!
Reload!
Good job.
Execute him!
Um, oh, I should reload.
I'm going to equip this and finish him.
Oh, I think it was my sanity was too low.
That was the sound.
Oh, whack!
A little whack there.
A little whack.
Yippee!
I should probably start using my sword more than the gun.
Yeah.
Um, I should start using my sword more than the gun.
Seventeenth is my birthday.
Can I have a happy birthday?
Sayo!
Happy early birthday!
Thank you for five months.
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Sayo.
Happy birthday.
Um, let's see.
Okay, my torch.
Gosh, I feel like this chapter is pretty long.
Oh my gosh.
Stop trying to get me.
There was that one guy.
We did not finish him.
So we'll have to remember that when we go back through that.
Oh, shoot!
When we go back through the hallway!
Oh, no!
Oh, no, no, no!
Oh, gosh!
Lindsay!
Lindsay, just run!
Why does it last the whole entire time?
It's so messed up.
Oh my god, run!
This way!
Oh, I got the rune!
Minus one!
Oh, we got the rune!
We got the rune!
Is there one more?
Yeah.
We finally got it.
Yippee.
Now we can summon things?
A damaged engraving on the wall depicts a skeletal demon befriending the ancient Khmer people.
To Lindsay's eye, the demon looks exactly like Paul...
I'm sorry.
Paul Augustine's...
Augustine's undisguised self.
It's not Jeff, it's Paul!
Wait, we've seen this, though.
I remember this, actually.
From when we saw this mural before, I'm pretty sure.
Looks just like Paul.
That guy with his eyes closed, like, aw, man.
I don't know.
That doesn't really look like befriending.
He's destroying your buildings.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, that guy was still alive.
How's our health?
Ooh, our sanity is quite low.
I will not accept to take your love.
Perfect.
I should probably get my sanity up a little bit.
I don't think I can save in here.
Nope, I didn't think so.
I know I wanted low sanity, but I'm also scared of dying.
I'm also scared of dying, you guys!
I can't save in that past room because of the traps.
Or in here.
What's gonna happen?
Is it gonna be the gas?
It's probably gas.
Why can't I cartwheel?
Just a big step, Lindsey.
Sorry, Lindsey.
I asked you of one...
I asked you of one thing, okay?
He's losing it.
Get away from me.
This is probably gas.
If you proceed too far, the small dog secret is permanent.
We should go back upstairs.
Wait, where are we anyway?
Can I loop around?
Back to the staircase?
If I go through this door down here?
Or should I loop all... Oh wait!
Oh, I can't!
That's right!
It's closed off!
Okay, let's go back.
We'll go back, we'll go back.
Oh shoot!
We're fine.
You're good.
All good, Lindsey.
Okay.
This way.
Thanks for reminding me.
I thought I would be able to do the loop like the other areas, but...
Clearly that's not the case.
What's this now?
Just a wall.
A late 50th birthday!
William, happy birthday!
Sorry it's late.
Happy birthday...
To you...
Ouch!
Happy birthday...
To you...
Get away from me.
Happy...
Birthday, dear William...
Happy birthday...
To you...
Sorry, the way he goes down the stairs...
Look at this.
Okay.
Head back.
This room has a guy in it.
Doesn't it?
Yes.
You son of a bitch.
Oh, he's not affected.
Wait a second!
No!
Why do you all come back?
Oh.
They're a figment of my imagination!
Their imagination!
Imagination!
My sanity!
I can't tell if they can actually hurt me though.
I wonder if I can save in here now.
Oops.
Oh, hell yeah!
The
ones that were dead before also were risen, I think.
I could do it.
Alright.
Okay, so...
You equip.
And I enchant.
You...
Blue...
Green is a weakness of blue?
Oh my gosh!
That's my gun.
Hello?
Wait, what just happened?
Oh.
I did the wrong thing.
I think I enchanted.
The wrong thing.
It even showed up on the screen.
It auto-equips whatever you enchant.
It showed up on the screen and I was just like...
La la la!
Oh, come on!
I can't!
Don't let him hit me!
Help me!
Is he dead?
Did I do it?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
They're all shooting and everything.
Okay.
I had a great idea.
I'm watching at work right now.
So I'm writing this off as a work expense.
Free money!
Thanks for watching!
Even though you're so busy.
Thanks guys for being here.
I know this game isn't the most popular one either but...
I really am liking it so much.
It's so weird.
Okay.
Yes.
Alright.
Into here.
And then...
Oh.
Oh!
Oh gosh!
I was hoping that wouldn't happen.
Wait, I don't know what that just did.
Maybe the same thing.
Okay, through here.
Alright, let's go.
I also have to learn the spell, don't I?
Okay, so new spell...
Oh, summon?
Summon...
Uh...
Item?
No.
Summon...
Project?
Creature?
Spell 6.
If I summon this thing, is it on my side?
Oh my god.
Do you guys see that fly?
I can't...
It's supposed to look like there's a fly on my monitor.
But it's part of the game!
So if I...
It doesn't matter if I...
If I...
Do with the red one if I...
You know, or...
Blue or green...
Does it all cast...
Does it all summon something different?
Oh!
Oh my god, there's bugs all over my screen!
Oh, they're gone now.
My sanity is...
A little crazy.
Wait a second.
Before we do that...
This looks like...
Okay, it looked like it was lighting up.
Okay.
Now we find...
But now we go back.
Okay, so we go down...
And over.
Okay.
Got it, got it, got it.
I can't go...
Wrong way.
It's hard to tell sometimes.
What's that sound?
What's squelching?
The ceiling is bleeding?
It's freaking me out a little bit.
How low is my sanity anyway?
It's pretty...
It's pretty low.
So if I press this button...
What is he staring at?
I can't.
It'll stop the traps for 30 seconds.
Oh, gross.
Just checking to make sure this is the right hallway.
It absolutely is.
Maybe I should have tested the...
Okay, so that was a lie.
It absolutely did not stop the traps for 30 seconds.
That was a lie.
Again.
I was slow?
I feel like 30 seconds is a pretty long time.
I don't know.
There's blood squelching out of your TV.
No!
Okay.
I'm gonna just try this one.
I summoned...
After a trapper has been summoned, press A to trap the enemy.
When it is targeted using R.
Press...
What the hell is that?
What button is that?
To release control of the trapper.
Oh, the start button.
Okay.
Trappers cannot open doors nor pick up items.
What is this gonna do?
Whoa!
What is this though?
No!
I can't get it though!
I'm just a little guy.
See ya.
Release control!
And he's activating traps.
Wait.
So he's not my friend though now, is he?
He's foe?
Oh my god.
So I have to kill him?
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
He's activating all the traps!
Se...
Secreted inside this alcove, a rune awaits its energy silently corroding the air about it.
Magical rune.
Why didn't you guys at least warn me?
What's gonna happen?
No!
Oh no.
Can I do anything with it?
Oh!
Oh wow, it's like a whole ass new rune!
Protect?
Summon the...
Protect.
Protect... me.
No, didn't work.
Okay, let's just take this guy out first, I guess.
Two... okay, he was... green.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Warning, when you pick up rune, big guy comes out.
New rune, protect item.
Let's see it.
I wanna see, I wanna see a new spell.
Protect... item.
No... didn't work.
Oh, it didn't work.
Oh, project!
Can't read?
What does it do, though?
I don't know what it does, though.
Enchant item with purple.
Oh...
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
I guess I'll try it.
Um...
Please!
Please aim for this guy, please!
Why aren't you aiming?
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
Why aren't you aiming?
Aaaaah!
Oh my God.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
I'm gonna die, you guys.
Oh!
I lived!
How did I live?
But there's another guy in there.
I also like blasted that... the little thing.
I think it's dead.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Are you...
Why do you have recordings of you on the toilet, sir?
Try to detect invisible with purple.
Oh...
Hold on, I'm getting my magic back up real quick.
We're gonna heal real quick before we go take on that other dude.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Try to heal with purple?
I'm scared, I don't even know what it does!
I don't even know what it does!
Wait, what was the...
Oh, what's the spell for healing?
Recover...
Is a...
Narrow...
Calf and Sand Talk.
Okay.
With...
Narrow Calf and...
Sand Talk.
You don't have to recreate it?
Oh, I like to do it!
Wait, so...
Hold on.
Oh, wait, not enchant.
Recover...
Cast...
Calf and Sand Talk.
It got...
It did both!
No way.
Mad Rock!
It did both!
Oh, it did all three?
It's cracked.
Wait, maybe I should put that as my quick spell then, right?
How do I do it again?
I'm trying to...
I'm pressing D-pad.
Let's see.
Okay.
Spell list.
Recover.
Oh, assign, assign.
You to there.
There we go!
Okay.
We'll do the top one.
Nice!
Wait, what was that one anyway?
Actually, I don't remember.
I know he's in there.
Oh, wow!
It did a lot too!
Holy cow!
Okay, I still gotta get my magic up though so I can re-enchant.
Oh, it was just enchant blue?
Okay, okay.
Yeah!
Every button is healing.
I'll change them later, now that we have this.
Sorry!
I wasn't ready!
Hold on!
I'm not ready!
Oh!
He's green.
I did the wrong one.
Use purple?
Is it really that strong?
Purple beats all!
So that's what it's for!
So I should just purple everything then.
Let's do here.
Wait, why did I get rid of the top one?
Can I only have one?
What?
That's so weird.
Weird?
Wait, recover, assign.
I'll do... There we go.
Okay, I'll just do it on Y then.
I'll just have to remember to push it.
Okay, okay.
Yo!
It's now enchanted.
Here I go!
Yeah!
Oh shoot!
Reload?
What was re...
Oh Z!
I only have four bullets left!
Guys, I think this might be a mistake.
Okay, hold on.
Yeah, these are... I don't think I should use this.
I think I'm just gonna run for it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna... because he's all the way... I have to shoot him.
That's the issue.
I think I'm just gonna run for it.
I think... because I should save it for like a final boss.
Right?
I think I should just...
I think I could just run and grab it and do this and then grab whatever's in there and then run out.
Because he's like on his own little island, I won't be able to like run over and attack him.
I don't need to kill him.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Here we go.
Pick it up!
Okay.
Okay!
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Get me out of here.
How do I get out of here?
Alright.
Okay.
Yippee!
Let's go back down.
Downstairs.
And continue onwards.
I can't even remember what we were doing.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, come on.
Here we go.
Okay.
Okay, we got the purple!
Gonna save... here.
Gosh, this... this chapter is so long.
I know I'm slow, but like...
This chapter feels mega long.
Yay!
Thank you!
Thanks for five months!
Okay.
It's here.
Here?
Yeah.
Okay.
Run, Lindsay!
Run!
Where are we going?
Okay.
We have to go through the loop.
We didn't get to the end of the hallway.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, come on.
Ah!
Gosh!
Just run!
No worries.
Get away from me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, just go!
Just go for it!
I'm going...
I'm a master at dodging.
No worries, everybody.
We're all good.
Oh.
Wow!
That takes a lot of magic.
Good to know.
Yeah, Lindsay's a champ.
He just takes it.
He really just like... eats those blades.
He's like...
Can't stop me now.
That's him.
He's really once... What's that guy?
Jeremy or whatever?
He's really...
He's just like... If you wrong me...
You're gonna get Lindsay'd.
No, not Jeff.
That's the name I made up.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh.
Onwards.
Rude.
So rude.
How did the people who lived here get through this?
They clearly knew how to use their legs and take big steps.
Or something.
Lindsay's the problem.
This is gonna open up, isn't it?
To another staircase or something, maybe?
There's a reason they all died?
No!
Okay.
This one activates wood.
Run, Lindsay, run.
Okay.
I can't forget English.
How far we've gotten.
How many hallways.
We've been through.
How many everything.
So now...
Yes.
Okay.
What's this gonna activate, you think?
What's this one?
Okie dokie.
And then this one activates a bunch of stuff, doesn't it?
Shoo.
Phew.
What's this one gonna activate?
Oh, come on.
I think they got faster.
I died.
You!
Activate...
This!
My blade is now enchanted and run.
I was not close enough.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many guys in here.
There's so many.
Ew.
It's just squelching everywhere.
It's just only squelch.
It's just squelching.
Non-stop squelching.
Get in a line.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Oh.
What's...
What's happening?
What's going on with them?
Ah!
What are they doing?
What are you doing?
No, no, no, no!
What just happened?
Oh, the blue ones explode.
I don't think I got hurt though.
Hold on, I'm not ready yet.
My camera is shaking and it's annoying.
Okay, let's recover sanity because my camera is annoying me.
Yeah, I saw the scroll.
Don't worry.
Squelches menacingly.
It's still... it's still...
Come on, Lindsey.
Get it together.
Get it together, man.
We're fine.
Okay, we're fine now.
Okay, let's grab this.
Wait.
A scroll of paper sits upon a ledge circling the...
The dais at the center of the room.
Oh, I have to pick it up.
They can sink and all explode at once.
It's a big enough blast to kill you anywhere in the room?
That's what got me.
No way.
Deus.
Summon trapper.
Oh.
Okay, good.
I thought that was going to activate like a trap in this room.
Wouldn't be the first time.
Yeah, the spell I learned myself.
Uh-huh.
I'm already smarter than you, game...
Oh, come on.
The shaking is annoying.
My sanity is not even that low.
Why am I so...
Why am I so wiggly?
You are sad, Zelda.
Huh.
I don't think that's a sanity effect.
Lindsay finds this mural frighteningly familiar.
It is the scene he saw in the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
The fertility god must be Manturok, and this temple must be its tomb.
Yes!
So we were here!
We were here!
Guys, remember?
Purple text.
Yeah, purple text.
Interesting.
Yeah, I don't know.
I didn't really get fertility, but...
You know.
That... whatever floats your boat, you know?
Oh, that's a tree.
I was like, how was I able to save when there's a body in here?
Alright, onward.
If the fertility goddess needs a Manturok, I will be that man.
Wait, this is...
Wait, isn't this where Manturok is?
Yes!
Wait, what's gonna be down here?
Oh.
He's still down here.
Hello!
Hey!
Don't mind me!
Hi!
You've been... how long has it been?
Oh my gosh!
Are you looking for a goddess of fertility?
The power of Mantarok is not easily controlled.
What makes you think I want to control it?
Arrogant man.
Kill him!
What?
Make sure you succeed this time.
Oh, come on.
Mantarok's on my side.
Yeah.
Get rocked.
No!
I have a torch.
The darkness is not coming.
This guy is so calm right now.
Holy cow.
Thank you for opening that up for me.
Is Mantarok on my side?
Hot lady.
Okay.
Wait, can I... Oh, dang it.
I was going to see if I could walk on top of Mantarok.
Wait, hold on.
I want to also... There was like another statue on this side too though, right?
Oops, sorry.
I'm walking on top of you a little bit.
Oh.
What happened to you, my goddess?
Oh my god.
What happened to you?
She's all legs.
The feet goddess.
I mean, when I say goddess of fertility, I'm just saying.
Oh my gosh!
Do not touch the heart, flesh, and bone, lest you become like me, a dead, rotted husk.
I have waited many centuries for you.
It was not easy hiding from the Dark Ones as they searched for me.
At first they passed by, not thinking that the heart was inside my dead body.
But I was forced to find refuge here.
You must seal the heart, so it never contacts your flesh, and take it to the Gathering of Light.
A museum!
It belongs in a museum!
Or the world shall fall under a rain of eternal darkness.
Eternal darkness.
She said the thing.
The veil of reality can only be pulled back so far, Myrtle.
Take your stand and fight the darkness.
She's gone.
Okay.
Don't touch it.
It's gotta be sealed.
Oh no!
Oh!
That's it?
Is that my grandpa?
Wait a second.
That's my grandpa!
Where is he putting it?
Oh, now we're gonna know where it's at.
It's behind!
I see!
Oh!
We finished the chapter!
Wait, there wasn't even a boss fight!
We did it!
Grandpa's a little freaky.
No one would ever check that book.
Clearly.
My little girl.
Oh, why was it green?
Let's restore my... I'm scared most of... actually...
No, I won't restore my sanity.
We're a little tilted, but...
I'm mostly scared of sanity in here because I feel safe in this area.
But I know I shouldn't feel safe in this area because, you know...
The boss is the purple spell.
Truly.
Save?
I think it saves automatically, but I will save...
Oh, it didn't save.
Hey, save fellas!
Did someone mention the door to darkness?
Did someone mention the eternal darkness?
Haha!
Pukwa Mickey!
No auto-saves.
Okay.
I say I feel safe here, but it's also so freaky in here.
Actually, I don't know where I feel.
I feel... I miss my torch.
I miss my torch and I miss my shotgun.
Actually, I feel very naked right now.
I don't feel safe at all.
Ah!
Okay, grandpa...
Grandpa?
Huh?
I know... I know where I sent...
Oh?
Grandpa?
Can that hurt us?
Um...
What is it doing?
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, it was here the whole time.
No one would check this book that's sideways.
Edwin H.
Lindsay!
The demon in the Khmer.
Alex discovers a pulp novel written by one Dr. Edwin Lindsay amongst the books on the shelf.
This is where the tomb of eternal darkness indicated that something of value was hidden behind the shelf.
This book.
Should Alex look behind the book?
Yes.
Ah!
It's just chilling there.
Oh my gosh.
With the book removed, a secret cache is revealed.
Inside is the heart of Mantarok.
It's just been chilling here this whole time.
Encased in glass to protect the world from its corrosive energies.
Should Alex claim the heart of Mantarok?
Um...
Sure.
I'm sure.
It's a secret.
And then...
I guess.
What in the beauty and the beast.
Oh my gosh.
I don't like this, I don't like this, I don't like this, I don't like this, I don't like this..
These are very... these are really creepy.
I'm also kind of getting tired of the Dutch angle, I'm not gonna lie.
Keep it low, you coward!
Yeah, I'm a coward!
It's scary!
Is the book gone?
I guess that was just my sanity.
So now we have...
this.
But my sanity effects... okay.
I'll let my sanity go back down, you guys.
I'll bring them back.
I was just scared, okay?
I was scared.
There was somebody walking and freaking me out.
So what do I do with this thing now?
I'm gonna codec my grandpa.
Grandpa!
So I have to use it to find...
the next chapter.
Let's go back this way, see if anything else changes.
There's still... I think it's this room.
Yeah, this room is...
a mystery...
for me.
There's so many levers and...
everything.
I did learn a new spell, that is true, but...
I don't think that this...
I have a feeling, I have an inkling that the spell doesn't...
isn't...
what's gonna help.
Because...
that seemed...
optional.
You know?
I feel like it seemed optional, because...
What?
What other?
Wait, hold on.
We have Manta Rock, but what else?
We have the summon?
We can summon a... something?
We can summon a trapper?
And we also have the dispel one.
Okay.
Which one was that?
Dispel magic?
That one's new too.
Wasn't there...
a seal somewhere?
I got rid of the one in here.
The second floor window!
Yes, thank you!
That's where it was!
Yes, yes, yes!
Okay, okay, okay.
Summoning other colors?
Yeah, I wanna see if...
Not just a trapper, but...
Yeah, the window over here.
That horse.
This...
Yes!
Red!
Goodbye, wall.
As the magical window fades away, the piece of parchment that the maiden was holding is left behind, floating in mid-air.
It's like...
It appears to be a chapter page.
Take it?
Yeah.
Heresy!
And this guy's like in my basement.
So...
You are...
Not in my basement.
Me too.
I am not your food today.
I am your master.
Oh!
Your task is to guard the artifact before you.
Let no one touch it.
Oh...
Oh, he part-gone too hard, you guys.
Oh, this is our chance!
We can leave!
What are you looking at?
Just...
Just jump!
Let's get out of here!
Who cares what's going on?
Wait.
Also this.
We know there's a room here.
Do we have...
We have the summon thing.
Will it work?
Reveal invisible, maybe?
Oh.
We got shot.
We went in that room in the past.
I remember.
Oh, with Venture Rocket makes me invisible?
Wait.
Really?
I'm see-through.
For how long?
Wait.
Hello?
I'm a ghost?
For real?
I'm actually a ghost?
Alright.
Oh.
I guess I didn't have to come back in here.
It just feels proper to read the chapter in here, you know?
Journal of M.
Roivas P...
Oh, wait.
Wrong one.
Like, when you hover over the page, it's like...
Should Alex read it now?
No.
What it says?
What is it?
Oh, oh.
Poor boy.
Oh.
1485.
Wait, we went back in time.
Well,
they did say the Inquisition, but...
Oh, you don't look okay.
I didn't realize we were going to go so back in time, I guess.
Okay.
Guy's not looking so good.
Brother?
Oh, you're giving me a back massage?
What is this?
Amiens appears to be a peaceful hamlet.
It appears to be.
But deviancy is secreted in the most deceptive places, which I believe is the case with Amiens.
Then I wish you luck in your search.
The Inquisition does not need luck, Brother Luther.
Faith and purity are our guides.
Oh...
Okay, I was just trying to be nice.
You don't have to be a jerk about it.
I have a meditation rod.
What the heck does this do?
The priest's meditation rod is a small staff used as a focus for meditative powers.
Oh, sorry.
Prayer.
Using it will allow Paul to meditate and regain some lost sanity.
I don't think Paul is going to wield a gun, is he?
I
have a feeling Paul is...
Whoa.
Wait, where was all the singing coming from?
Okay, spooky.
Crunchy PBJ!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
For the love of God!
Guards!
Help!
Come quickly!
Uh-oh.
They're looking mighty suspicious.
A murder!
A murder most foul!
What heresy is this?
I... I found him lying here.
Heresy!
I called the guards.
Is this our first suspect?
What?
Make sure no one touches the body.
I just got here!
He must be examined for signs of devilry.
Devilry.
As for this man...
Oh.
Make sure he doesn't leave the cathedral.
I will question him later.
I'm sorry.
What?
Says the guy that literally looks like a snake.
Hold up, Tom.
Or it might bring my wrath upon thee.
Who is to say that you did not commit this murder?
If you trust in the Almighty, and you are indeed innocent, then you will have nothing to fear.
Can you speak up?
Are they gonna...
Wait, they literally locked me away.
What is this?
I didn't get to go upstairs.
The painting captures Paul's attention.
A small emerald disguised as part of the painting.
Glints in the candlelight, as though it has some value beyond being a precious gem.
Paul!
That's devilish!
You're gonna steal from the church?
This is one of the best chapters in the game.
I'm excited.
Paul!
Very good.
Joink!
Are you here to pass sentence on me?
No.
I'm here to free you.
You are in incredible danger.
This cathedral used to be a place of peace.
What happened?
Now many strange things happen here.
Oh, yeah.
I don't want you to end up like the others.
What do you mean?
The look on his face is so funny.
The body you found was Brother Andrew.
And he was killed.
You're the one who killed him!
A secret.
Yeah.
So true.
Oh my gosh, it's Slender.
I have to collect the seven pages.
Okay.
Is this a sneaking mission?
Is this...
Am I gonna have to sneak past the guys?
What's this one?
Oh, I can barely even see it.
Sorry.
Is this the face of a holy man?
What's this?
A framed fragment of written verse.
It is in Latin and makes references mostly to diabolical entities and how man is dominated by them if he strays from the rights of protection.
I'm scared.
You old foxhound.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Devil.
Devilish.
Devilry.
Wait.
Who is this?
Oh, wait.
That's Augustus.
We're missing...
Why isn't he here?
Oh, he hasn't happened yet.
Okay.
Thank you.
Take the tome.
Yeah.
Shut up.
Be quiet.
Okay.
That was pretty devilish.
Wait.
I want to see the emerald.
Flex the light inside it perfectly.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry if I start yawning a lot, you guys.
Probably what's going to keep me um...
uh...
from doing such a long stream today.
I was really planning on going super long today, but I'm so tired.
I'm so sorry.
But I still want to beat this chapter.
Paul cannot leave the cathedral until his name is cleared and the real murderer has been uncovered.
To run away now would be an admission of his guilt.
I mean...
So I'm just going to go to the bell tower?
Let's go.
I have nothing with me though.
I'm so scared.
If I have the Tome of Eternal Darkness, that means the demons can get me.
I have nothing to protect myself.
This chapter is pretty long.
That's okay.
I have nothing to protect myself.
How am I supposed to...
Wow.
Don't do it!
Dodge.
Yeah, pretty much.
I'm just going to have to run around him.
Ah!
Yeah, yeah.
Don't get stuck.
Okay.
Okay, um...
I guess we're going up.
Oh, Maximilian Roivis' statue is from...
is there?
And he's from 1760.
Yeah, that's right!
It's not a matter of when in history that causes the statue.
Oh.
Interesting.
Is it a...
Is it death?
Well, I mean...
Because if the grandpa was alive...
Then...
Um...
Well...
I guess he didn't use the toe.
Well, I don't know.
But like...
You know what I mean.
The grandpa was alive.
And we knew our grandpa.
And that guy gave us the heart.
So Lindsey must have...
Could still be alive.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Okay.
We're just gonna keep going up.
Let's go.
Let's climb!
Let's climb, brother!
This is the...
bell tower, right?
Um...
Hello?
What is this room?
Never mind.
This is...
What?
Huh?
Okay.
See ya!
No.
Grandpa is not a statue.
Um...
I don't know.
Did I go through here?
Or this is where I came from.
Ring the bell!
It didn't give me an option to.
Okay.
We're dancing.
I'm just gonna walk away.
Alright.
See ya!
See ya, dummy!
We...
We can go into the main area.
I suppose.
Okay.
I came from that door over there.
I feel like this guy is just walking around a little too freely.
For someone who's afraid of like, you know, For someone who's afraid of like, you know, being marked as the culprit.
I feel like this guy is...
Just kind of like...
A little too nonchalant...
About just kind of...
Chillin' around...
This church.
Oh, there's a door over here.
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, you got a torch!
All is well.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh.
A heavy wooden chest sits up against the room's wall.
It appears to be old and worn.
Yeah.
A crossbow?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay!
The rack carries robes and cloaks for ceremonial use.
As per...
Paul draws the robes back, something tumbles from inside.
A podium key!
Dang, this room is...
Stacked.
Oh!
Mori Calliope.
A woodcut depicting the effects of a plague.
The spirit of death incarnate casts final judgment over a wealth of victims.
The people in the background kind of look like how, you know, in renaissance paintings they draw cats.
That's what they remind me of.
Check the other one.
What other one?
Oh, this one?
Oh!
Oh, what's going on here?
A woodcut shows an act of blasphemy!
A host of demons prey upon humans like they were playthings, disemboweled by mocking demons, eaten or tortured by other carnal deviant acts.
I can't tell what's going on though.
Why would you hang that up in the church?
Why?
Why is that hung up here?
We can play!
What are you looking at?
Characters in old games like stare at...
at things.
You know, it freaks me out.
Playing the organ is a daunting challenge for someone like Paul who has no musical talent.
Paul could probably play the organ if there was some music to play.
Paul, don't sell yourself short!
What do you mean?
Sneaking around a giant building, avoiding the guards, discovering a conspiracy.
But this time it's Cole Campbell.
What a twist!
The altar is bereft of holy adornment.
No crucifix, no bible, no sacrament of any kind.
Paul is disturbed by this sight.
What faith does the order practice?
What is this?
Oh, is this a basement?
Oh!
He said we should go to the Bell Tower?
I think that implies going up.
Oh, what's this over here?
Paul is voiced by Paul Eide...
What?!
No way!
No he's not!
I got some bolts!
The cathedral's tabernacle is fashioned from age.
Varnished mahogany.
Its doors are closed and there doesn't appear to be any way of opening them in many.
Colonel!
I couldn't hear it at all.
Alright Paul, I'm gonna need you to speak.
We're gonna get his sanity real low so he can say something.
Oh, Paul notes that the door to the old tower is locked.
Perhaps the custodian might have the key.
So this is the podium key.
What does a podium key go to?
For the podium and the cathedral apes?
Apes?
A podium?
Yeah, but I'm just checking where it is.
The custodian is Cam Clark!
I mean, I know that this is Silicon Knights, but we've had other Metal Gear people in the game earlier.
Maybe I should go downstairs.
Okay, let's go downstairs.
Okay,
let's go downstairs.
Spooky.
Freaky.
What's down here?
Oh, crossbow.
The sound is so funny.
The personal effects of a priest are scattered across the shelves.
Rosary beads and crucifix and a variety of other small holy items.
Paul believes they must have been Brother Andrews.
Okay, what makes you think that?
A desk bears a leather-bound book.
Book of Reliquaries.
It's weird to hear Cam Clark say brethren.
Different accent than usual, right?
What's this?
Oh.
No comment.
Okay.
Nice.
Can this book also be picked up?
No.
Okay.
Clam Clark.
I don't even like clams.
Ooh.
What's this down here?
What is this?
Oh.
The bellows mechanism supplies the organ upstairs with air.
It requires an expert hand and attention to keep it in working order.
What?
I wonder if this is kind of accurate.
What's this?
Near the organ, a steel base is mounted on the back wall by means of a display armature.
Holy cow!
We got a mace!
I mean, I'm still gonna just kind of hold on to the...
I'm still gonna hold on to our torch is number one, I'm just gonna say.
But...
Oh...
No, it's a trapper!
Um...
How do I kill these things again?
Sounds like there's more than one.
I can't tell though.
Did I kill it?
Wow!
One shot!
Okay, reload.
I have to remember to do that.
Okay.
I think we got him.
That's it?
Ooh!
These camera angles!
What am I examining?
A wine cask used for...
Why?
Who knocked?
We'll just...
Used for maturing wine.
The wine inside this one must be very strong for it seeps through the cask, filling the air with a heady aroma.
How about this one?
Boom, boom, boom.
I'm just knocking on the barrels.
Okay.
Is there something on one of the...
Is there something I must find?
In one of these heady aromas?
Oh!
Knocking on this cask results in a hollow thud.
It is empty!
But why, when all the others are full of maturing wine?
Yes.
Turned!
Turn!
Hold on before I get too far.
Um...
I don't think we've saved at all.
There we go.
Paul Luther!
I don't...
Oh!
Paul...
I don't think we're ready...
I don't think we're...
You know Paul.
Let's go back to the bell tower.
See if I missed anything there.
Once more.
You know...
Could be something.
Blue guy...
Okay, so I have to enchant...
Yeah, like where's the podium exactly?
There's stuff that we...
are looking for.
Real quick.
My sanity isn't that low.
What the hell was that?
What did that...
What did that mean?
I'm confused.
What was that trying to...
Ambiance?
I don't think so.
Because we haven't heard that at all before even once.
What?
Maybe it's telling me to go to the clock tower.
Hey!
What are you looking at?
All these?
Just waiting for it to die?
I hear you!
What?
What are you...
It actually kind of makes me like a little...
Little like...
You know that...
Pit you get in your stomach when you...
Are going down on a ride?
Like a roller coaster?
My sanity isn't that low.
I think Paul is very susceptible.
Perhaps.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait!
Paul is nervous about ringing the bell.
Fearing his own capture.
It is the custodian's...
Task to ring the bell at appropriate times.
Perhaps he will...
Be by later to ring it.
Should Paul ring the bell anyway?
Yes?
I saved not too long ago.
It's okay.
Oh my god!
Ah, brother Luther.
Not a moment too soon.
As you have noticed...
This is Camp Clark?
Great things inhabit this place.
Shambling corpses.
Yeah.
There is darkness at work here.
In the midst of the Inquisition.
Okay, I hear it.
I suspect it is worse than that.
I hear Colonel.
Brother Andrew knew this also.
And paid the price.
Why are you telling me this?
Perhaps you can think of where Andrew started.
Take this key.
It unlocks the old tower.
It has been sealed off since the Inquisition arrived.
I intend to uncover the truth behind this.
If you manage to uncover the source of darkness, return here.
And I will do everything I can to help.
Till then, brother.
I will be waiting for you.
Brother?
May your faith protect you.
And my torch.
Old tower key.
Yes.
Okay.
The custodian shakes his head and informs Paul that he doesn't have enough evidence to make an accusation against Augustine.
Augustine.
There must be something else to find.
Okay.
See you.
Cool.
Okay.
The old tower.
Clock tower.
All these...
Spooky games having...
Having...
Towers in them.
Okay.
I just saved recently but...
Save again.
So that we can...
Okay.
Isn't Paul's voice the same as Campbell's?
Like Colonel?
Like...
Metal Gear Solid Colonel?
Yeah.
Paul Eiding?
Paul Eiding is the voice actor's name.
But the character in this game is also named Paul.
But where does this key...
Wait.
It says...
In the cathedral...
What is that?
I don't even know what that room is.
And it doesn't...
It doesn't give a name or anything.
In here?
It's not to this, right?
Oh wait.
Oh!
A single podium and lectern provides a platform for a priest giving a sermon to his congregation.
There's a drawer!
Open.
Wow!
I didn't realize that this was a podium.
A diary page lies inside the open drawer.
Yes!
Okay.
This is the evidence we're supposed to find though, right?
We got a diary page!
A diary of Brother Andrew.
Page 1.
I have finally arrived at...
Amiens.
And my pilgrimage to see the hand of Jude draws to a close.
I cannot wait to lay eyes upon the sacred relic.
My journey here has been arduous.
And it shall be good to relax for a while in this peaceful village.
Amiens...
Aliens.
Aliens is full of good people.
Strong in their faith and their rule in our world.
If the blight of witchcraft is present in this world, then I doubt it is in aliens.
Okay.
That is not the tea we need.
We need the evidence of them committing terrible crimes.
Devilish crimes.
Let's go!
Oh no, not these things again!
Oh no, no, no.
Oh, uh...
Um...
Ah!
Oh shoot!
Oh gosh, I forgot this thing!
How do I...
Ah!
I think we got it.
Finish him!
Holy cow.
Oh my god, my sanity.
It ate all my sanity in one go.
Our health is okay.
Not bad.
Could be worse.
We're fine.
Just a little...
A little funky.
Feeling okay, Paul?
It's probably fine.
I hate those...
I forgot all about...
Wait!
It's this place!
Oh my god.
The scroll of aged paper sits on the dusty altar top.
Seems to have been discarded.
We've been here before!
Shields?
What's that?
Oh!
Ah!
Thank you.
Yeah,
I remember this guy...
was in there and...
There was like a body in there...
and we tried to go in here to warn...
the guy...
Oh my god.
Ah!
Turn around!
I thought
that was real!
I thought that was real for real!
Oh my gosh.
The game got me good.
I was like...
They literally one-hit me.
Oh.
Ah!
Happening!
No, no!
I'm on your side!
He's yellow.
Uh...
Um...
I'm on your side!
Ah!
I guess I'll just mace him to death.
Well, I mean...
To whatever after that.
Oh!
Are you okay?
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
I don't think I can kill him.
I think I should leave.
Yet.
Maybe.
Maybe I can't kill him...
I can right now?
I can?
Oh god.
Oh, that other guy.
We didn't care about him.
We're not gonna pray for him.
But this guy will...
Oh...
Oh my gosh.
We were brothers.
Oh, there he goes!
Goodbye, Anthony.
What else is in here?
What's this?
He's just been chilling in here this whole time?
That's it?
There's nothing...
They...
They just locked you in here?
Poor guy!
Yep, that's all that's in there.
Okey dokey!
Um...
And we were... I remember...
Uh...
Upstairs...
There was...
That hidden room...
Remember in here?
Oh shit.
Ah!
Ugh!
I hate these... I hate these guys so much.
Sorry.
I'm trying to take out his other arm.
Yeah!
Finish him!
Yeah, they're so...
Annoying.
What's this?
She music!
Wonder...
One wonders what it sounds like.
A... B... Y...
X... B... Y...
A... B...
Y...
Oh no.
Am I actually gonna have to play?
Hey, where's the secret hole?
Laying on an abandoned easel is a sheet of tattered paper covered with Oh!
Yippee!
Oh!
You okay?
Sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt you.
I'm just gonna read the diary.
Diary of Brother Andrew, page 2.
I suppose it is an understandable...
Oh, it is understandable that they will not show me the hand of Jude on such little notice.
But I must confess that the preparations they make are most unusual.
No acts of consecration, no daily prayer or worship are demonstrated by this strange order.
One wonders if they are holy at all, let alone being under the auspices...
auspices...
of the Grand Inquisition.
Perhaps it is my naivety...
my naivety...
of our faith.
There are many practices associated with it, and they differ greatly from region to region.
Perhaps one of our aliens is merely more eccentric than others.
A bewildering array of books and tombs, sorted neatly onto this set of shelves.
Mostly books of a religious nature, awaiting scholars such as Paul to peruse their contents.
Oh my gosh!
Paul!
You're a scholar!
Hmm...
Wait, what was that?
He's a scholar...
You guys, I was gonna say...
that I would play for a long time, but I'm fading so fast.
Oh my gosh, it's only 5pm for me.
I can't wait for me to go to bed.
Can't wait till bedtime.
I'm so sleepy.
Sorry if I'm a little less energetic.
Hmm...
Fighting the jet hag.
Was there any arrows in here?
Wait...
Was there anything...
Wait, what was even here?
There wasn't even anything...
Did I miss something?
Hahaha...
Oh, I was tiny?
It's average...
Average Sunday.
Okay...
So we have two pages of the diary.
Let's go do the sheet music, I suppose.
Scary!
How's our sanity?
It's pretty low.
Doing fine.
What are you looking at?
What's here?
Oh!
Why is he looking up at the wall like that?
He's not okay.
Hahaha...
Alright, Paul.
Don't worry about it.
You're a-okay.
Oh...
Um...
Oh, should Paul play the organ?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh...
What is that?
What is that for real?
That's the first time we've heard that, I think.
Hahaha...
The tabernacle is almost empty.
There are none of the things that should be there, such as holy water and other ritualistic items.
Only a circle of power laying on the lower shelf.
Oh...
Oh man, we're powerful!
Circle of power...
Oh!
Paul has acquired a five-point circle of power!
Oh my gosh, they even have an exclamation point.
They're like, yeah!
Now, each of the three-point spells can be powered up by using the power rune!
I still don't know what this one is.
I just have it.
I missed the translation.
I can't remember.
Paragon!
I don't have a power-up, though.
Do I?
So, what do I do?
New spell?
Oh my gosh!
What do I even create?
We don't have Paragon yet.
No, we don't have Paragon yet.
I don't...
...
Um.
Summon...
...
... creature...
... item...
... and also...
... myself!
...
Oh.
Tried shield first.
Oh, that's true!
I haven't done shield.
...
Where is that shield...
Wait, wait.
People are saying shield is golden.
Where is it?
What was... wait, hold on.
Spell list?
I already have it, actually.
Now that I think about it.
Yeah.
I already... I don't have to discover it.
Sorry.
Oh gosh, my brain is moving at like 2 bpm right now.
Tattered scroll aligned with curious writing and diagrams.
It reads, from all manner of magic you will be protected when encased in this...
Geass?
What you call me?
The alignments can help but never hinder.
For within the well conjured magic comes greater protection.
Code Geass.
Two brains per minute?
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
Yeah, two brains per minute.
So... Alright.
We have...
Two...
Gemi's?
I think we gotta go back downstairs and fight that guy.
No!
When you finish the game, you should look at footage of the N64 version.
Paul supposedly has a weapon too advanced for the time period?
Let's go.
Go back to the first room for a sanity effect.
Hey...
Oh... like the room we started out in?
Did they give Paul a gun?
For real?
...
Ew, what's squelchy in here?
Oh my god.
...
What's squelching?
Oh!
...
Ceiling's leaking again?
It's like taking a bite.
It's like taking a bite of an apple or something.
The random screams are so funny.
Oh, there's blood here too.
We're still squelching a little.
Okay, I think I gotta go downstairs and fight that guy.
No!
I don't want to!
Okay.
It was... not here.
Invisibility on him?
We can try.
Let's see.
We have so much stuff now.
I'm thinking I'll probably put up the shield and then crossbow him.
How many?
I have 13, but crossbow?
I don't know.
Actually, I feel like I should mace him.
Well, the crossbow is good, but it's slow, you know, to reload.
Purple barrier and enchanted mace.
Oh!
So true, actually.
That actually might be good.
It was blue.
The guy was blue, so it should be green.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me make sure where...
It's this room, right?
I'm just gonna double check.
No, it's this room down here.
Okay, good, good.
It's this room down here.
Oh, don't just run in there, Paul.
Gosh, I'm not ready.
I'm not ready, Paul.
First, I want to...
Wait.
Miracle stand.
Mostly did that for our health.
Uh-oh.
Stinky.
And I'm gonna... Or I'm gonna enchant and then I'm gonna save.
Order of operations here.
So, shield, cast, purple.
Okay.
And then, spell, enchant, cast.
On to you, my mace.
And then, save the game.
Yes, indeed.
I think I'm gonna save over this one too, just in case.
I'm paranoid now after I had like my memory... or not my memory card, but I had my like game freeze on me yesterday for Metal Gear Solid.
So... Okay, let's go.
Oh, uh, he's still hurting me.
Isn't he?
Oh, my shield is, uh...
Ah!
My shield's gone.
Um, that's not good.
Um, that didn't last very long, did it?
Um, can I make another shield?
That was so fast.
Okay, Paul!
Let's go for it!
Paul, I think we're gonna die, Paul!
Oh, he's zapping my energy.
Oh, he's zapping my magic, that's what's happening.
Paul, I don't think we're gonna make it, but that's okay.
You do your best, Paul.
Um...
I'm gonna go in with a crossbow.
Hahaha!
The only useful shield is red for health.
Otherwise, you lose shield points every time an enemy sees you.
Wait, really?
Paul has perished at the hands of the eternal darkness!
With no one to stop their diabolical plans, humanity will surely be annihilated!
Bum bum bum!
Alright, let's do...
Crossbow instead.
It's fine, because I saved right before.
Hahaha!
I don't...
Maybe I don't understand the shield.
The darkness comes!
I'm so scared.
Okay.
But I also should enchant it, maybe?
Reload.
Let's just zap him.
Reload!
Hahaha!
Oh!
I was so close.
I tried to reload.
Reload!
Oh my gosh!
Run, Paul, run!
Reload!
I'm...
Now reload.
Reload!
Oh my gosh.
This is a little silly.
I think I'm gonna like...
Wait!
What the...
Huh?
What?
The purple poisons?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I only have nine left.
Oh no!
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay, there we go.
Haha!
Yippee!
We did it!
You're losing two points of shield per attack from blue horror because it would do health and magic damage.
Purple protected against bullets.
I see.
Hidden in the alcoves of this mausoleum lie the remains of departed monks.
Some have turned to dust while others have grotesquely withered, leaving husks of bone and leathery skin.
Okay.
Why you gotta be so rude to them?
Is there anybody in here?
No?
Okay.
Let's get this thing.
Whatever this is.
Oh!
This should be...
The pedestal has three small indentations adorning its top, arranged in a circular formation.
Each socket appears to be waiting for something.
I think we have all three.
Use...
...
Okay.
The music?
Chill out.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
Tiny guy!
So tiny!
You are so small!
You are so small, little guy!
Nothing can stop my torch!
I like to wait until they are dead-dead though.
Just so that...
Just in case they try to respawn in this room or something.
I don't know.
Yeah, laugh at the small guy.
Laugh at how small he is.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, you're a big guy!
Doesn't matter!
Yeah!
Is that guy looking at me?
Oh my god!
That guy is looking at me!
Eww!
What rune did we just get?
Mystery.
I think this is the one.
Or... yeah.
This is the one we just got, right?
Stop staring!
Nothing else in here.
Right?
Okay, on for it.
My sanity is so low.
No, Paul!
You have to shut up!
Oh my god, here he comes!
There he comes!
Can I light this?
No.
Anybody else?
Anybody else down here?
Pretty spooky in here.
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
Refill my sanity before going in there.
Yeah, we might need to...
We might need to...
Okay.
Let's get you up to speed there, buddy.
Okay, wait.
Oh...
Yeah, if I take any...
Yeah, if I take any sanity damage, it'll...
Yeah, actually kill me.
Like, it'll actually take my health.
Oh, um...
Oh, shit.
We're just gonna have to run around and...
But there's like so many...
There were at least two guys in there, right?
Okay.
Alright.
Try making a five star shield.
Wait, I'm gonna run around first and then I'll save again.
Oh yeah, my rod!
I forgot about my rod!
My rod!
You okay, buddy?
Don't throw up.
You're okay.
Um...
So, protect?
Self?
Then the last rune twice.
Oh.
Shield spell.
Five point spell.
Paragon, paragon!
Oh my gosh.
Looks...
Looks like we don't have that many spells left, really.
Paragon, paragon.
So, if I do everything...
with paragon, paragon at the end...
Is it gonna be, like, super powerful?
And Terbok...
Mag...
Or more.
Oh, new spell.
and...
And Terok.
Oh, and Terbok...
Macklemore.
Where are you?
Oh, there.
Paragon, paragon.
Oh my god!
Oh gosh!
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm really fading fast, but I want to keep playing.
And I also don't want to go to sleep so early.
I don't want to have to go through all of these, though.
It's kind of a pain in the butt, isn't it?
Recover is...
Narrow Coth and Sontac.
Narrow Coth...
And Sontac.
Sontac...
Bargon!
Yeah!
That one was really clear.
Sometimes you can't really tell what they're saying, but that one was like...
Clear as day.
Oh!
If I... Okay.
Is it a Trapper every time?
Even with these other...
Spells?
The blue one and the green one?
I don't know.
So it is a Trapper every time.
But maybe...
With the five... Let's see.
Check.
Uh...
Tear and Airtac.
Tear...
Airtac.
Bargon!
Now what do we have?
Spell eight?
Oh!
I want to cast it.
I want to cast it, but...
What is it?
I'm scared.
Will it help me in battle?
Let's try it.
I summoned a man!
Oh no way!
I shouldn't have picked red!
Oh no!
I'm going to have to kill him afterwards!
Press A to attack enemies.
Attacks can be targeted using R.
Attack an enemy's head to perform a gnaw attack.
Press L...
Okay, so run.
Zombies can open doors, but not pick up items.
Here I go.
They're not going to suspect it's me.
I think they're fighting.
The girls are fighting.
Hey!
I'm just a zombie.
Don't mind me.
I'm a zombie.
I also don't know how to go upstairs apparently.
Oh!
Yes I do.
Ah!
Hold on!
Gosh!
Oh!
He won't let me get close to him.
Uh...
If I...
Hmm...
Uh...
But now I have to deal with this zombie.
Now I have to deal with this guy.
Where else can we go?
Look!
That doesn't seem like a door.
Okay, so now we know that there's just the red guys left though.
So we're gonna have to...
Let the big guy kill you.
No, he's only draining my sanity.
He's not killing me.
He's only draining... does... maybe...
Oh, shoot!
I got a hit in!
My zombie!
Dang, he took a good amount of sanity too.
We got in a single hit, everybody.
Let's go.
Yeah, you got in a single hit.
Oh, he really did do his job.
I'm actually quite proud of him.
So for this guy...
Mr. Red...
I'm scared of using the mace.
I feel like I'm not gonna...
Let's see if I...
Enchant item.
We're gonna enchant our mace.
Okay, we've got the mace.
It's almost the last one.
Good.
I think I can actually get this one.
Okay, and then I'm gonna also...
Oh, I don't have enough.
As a shield.
If I die.
Then I will come back and do it all over again.
Oh.
I'm not doing a very good job at it.
Hmm.
I'm trying to hit him, but I'm not...
Ah!
Maybe I can hold out?
And he can poison to death.
Ow!
Oh, don't die, Paul!
Paul!
Paul, just let him...
Oh gosh, Paul, I think we're done, Zo.
Wait.
Oh, Paul.
I think we're dead.
Oh my god.
Just let him...
Oh, he's slow, he's slow.
Dang it.
Paul...
Paul!
It's okay.
It's all good.
Let's see.
This is the one, yeah.
Paul!
This is what happens when Colonel is on his mission.
And accidentally... accidentally dies.
So...
Let's get my magic up a little.
Just gonna run up and down the stairs.
How do we want to approach this?
This is like so tricky.
Before we had our shotguns, it was really nice.
Now all we have is Paul's wit.
Or his might.
Come on, Paul.
We need you to really... you know...
80s training montage.
This is Paul's idol training.
He's training to become Love Live.
Oh my god, he doesn't sound so good.
Okay.
Almost
there.
I will also do a spell...
Wait.
Recover.
Just evil church things, you know?
Whatever.
Love me some Paragon.
Hell yeah.
Can I get a Paragon in the chat?
Can we all say...
Paragon!
I hope one day...
if it hasn't happened already...
that somebody plays this game at...
at AGDQ...
and then instead of, can I get a hype...
can I get a Paragon?
Everyone's just like, Paragon, Paragon...
Paragon...
Okay, alright.
Our magic is full.
Our sanity is full.
Our health is full.
It has been.
There was a...
speedrun of it.
Um, okay.
Now I can at least shield.
I can shield and mace.
So let's...
do that.
Uh, the game is bleeding...
again.
Sorry.
Let Paragons be Paragons.
Um, enchant item...
cast...
purple to mace.
I...
wanna try mace one more time.
Actually, before I do that, I'm gonna save...
so that we have all my...
stuff maxed, you know?
The speedrun is interesting...
but it loses a lot because it revolves around...
managing your sanity to make sure there are no...
time waste of events.
Ahhhh...
That makes sense though.
That does make sense.
I keep closing out of the menu.
Okay.
Mace!
And also...
shield.
Oh!
Noooo!
I accidentally touched my...
My finger...
slipped!
My finger slipped.
Ahhhh!
Noooo!
My finger slipped on my controller.
Hmm...
Um...
Load save.
Should be okay.
Um...
Ohhhh...
Load save.
Hahaha!
Yippee!
The dark just comes!
Hahaha!
Blue recover spell.
But okay, shouldn't it be purple so that I can be...
protected against everything?
Why should I do a blue recover spell?
I know he's blue, but...
Oh, recover.
Not shield.
Ohhhh!
Well, not... I don't need an owl.
Um...
Okay.
Alright, shield.
Sleepy as yod.
I'm...
I'm telling you, when I'm tired...
I'm so tired today.
But I'm trying to get through it.
Okay.
Mace.
So sorry if I'm a little, uh...
Extra, you know...
Dummy.
My spell is gone!
Or my shield is gone!
Oh!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, Paul!
You did it!
I got... I got some crossbow bolts.
Yeah!
Good job, Paul!
What is this?
Oh!
Oh, it's a piggy bank.
An effigy of a monk...
reclining on the sacrificial altar.
A deep groove...
bisects...
its chest.
Uh...
Bisects...
bisects...
You know what I was saying!
This face looks almost exactly like the custodian!
The inscription reads...
Only when thy friend is sacrificed, when his cries fill the air, will the great doors be opened to thee.
Do I have to sacrifice the custodian?
No way.
That's my buddy.
What is growling?
Excuse me?
The door is locked?
There's something in that box!
What about this one?
Oh, Mantarok Enchantment makes a growling sound when you hit!
Oh my gosh!
That's so funny!
It's about to be...
Oh wait, I was gonna hit save.
Sorry.
Save's coming!
Coming!
Oh!
Ah!
I hit him!
He was like...
A 10 don't know for a 10 out of 10.
Oh, Paige!
Thank you!
Why?
What happened?
Why are we being nice, huh?
Why are we being nice to Minto?
Okay.
Oh shoot, it's these guys.
Dang it!
Hold on, let's go enchant.
Let's go enchant!
Thank you!
Enchant My Messa!
It kinda sounds like they're saying Pekora Paragon.
Okay!
Here I go!
So...
Bow!
Take that!
Yeah!
You don't get your head back.
No head!
Yeah!
As further proof of the heresy within this dark cathedral, a table bears arcane documents.
Diagrams and sigils pertaining to demonic craft are scattered across the recently used table.
Heresy, heresy, heresy, heresy!
Oh my gosh, we got crossbows.
Wow!
Um...
Uh...
Yeah, we have all the evidence we need, I think.
Arcane documents and treatments of the demonic arts.
Paul daren't touch them for fear of the taint of evil.
I'm also afraid of the evil taint.
What?
This is a door, isn't it?
Da... The shelf appears to be recessed into the wall.
Not quite as flush as the others in the room.
Almost as if it could slide inward.
Yes.
I'm scared.
Oh, um...
I shouldn't be... I have...
my torch!
I was just hitting the wall.
Could've been better.
Thank you so much for the $50,000!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Okay.
Onward.
I remember this area, kind of.
I don't remember what I...
Like, I remember each room as like...
We continue onward.
You know?
Okay.
Those are my footsteps.
Oh my gosh!
This looks like... What?
Tucked into a niche within the wall!
A stone tablet!
Awww...
Paragon!
Yeah!
By adding Paragon runes to a spell, it can be powered up, intensifying its effects!
Paragon!
Let's go!
This seems to be...
Holy texts.
A torn diary page has been placed on the shrine.
It says Paragon, Paragon, Paragon, Paragon, Paragon, over and over again.
I've got the diary page!
Now what does it say?
For real.
Page 3.
The diary of Brother Andrew.
I would give my life for Paragon.
Don't do that!
Don't do it!
Funky Nighty!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you so much!
With a shudder, my heart turned to ice.
I came to the brutal realization that the entire Order were heretics!
And that I was in incredible jeopardy.
Who knows how long they had kept their dark secret, masquerading as custodians of the Hand of Jude.
When in fact, they guarded a damnable relic.
The essence of the unholy...
...
Use IT!
Whenever you see IT capitalized, I think of IT.
Use IT to lure potential victims to their hideous sacrifice.
I felt sick.
And despite my faith, I felt intense fear and hopelessness.
I know that I must escape this place before they suspect my knowledge.
I must warn the world and notify the real inquisition of their presence.
Knowing death...
Yeah, Paul does not know what a computer is.
Knowing death is just around the corner and fearing every moment, I commit these words to paper.
Augustine will find this book.
I will remove certain pages and hide them, so that all who may follow might discover the truth before it is too late.
...
I think we've got all the evidence we need, baby.
I think it's time to go back to the bell tower.
And talk with...
the custodian.
...
Which sounds like a secret boss, you know?
The custodian.
...
Let's keep going.
Alrighty.
Oh, but I think we have to sacrifice our friend, don't we?
Custodian!
It doesn't look anything like him.
It says it looks like him.
I don't know about that.
I think a custodian is much more handsome.
I don't know.
Oh, he's still looking at me.
Is my sanity that low?
...
Oh, wait.
Let me replace that with, um...
with the five star one.
Recover.
Assign.
Five star.
To you.
Oh, to you.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Now we're normal!
Yeah!
We're normal!
...
Unless it's just, you know...
I mean, we're in a fantastical world.
I would assume that sometimes statues stare at you.
I think it's just normal.
Camera angles, please.
...
Alright.
Go back upstairs.
...
You lost interest!
I think the statue realized I'm out of his league.
...
It's not a matter of losing interest.
He's very much interested.
He's just like, Oh, gosh.
I don't think I can...
I don't think I'm worthy.
Did I go in here?
Yes, I did go in there.
Just kidding.
...
And then we...
Oh, sorry, Paul.
Making you... I'm really putting you to work.
...
Sorry, I'm checking the map real quick.
The bell tower...
...
Didn't lead anywhere.
Yeah, we just gotta go back.
...
Yeah, Paul's got some crazy stamina.
Yeah, he does.
Oh, my bad.
...
This way...
Friend, I have three pages of diary.
...
And they're all going to prove that...
Thanks, girl.
It's okay.
Mm-hmm!
Murdered!
Oh, my God!
It was a trap!
Ah!
No...
What the...
What does that... what?
They want you to do it?
Oh, my gosh.
They gave you a weapon.
Fight back!
Can you speak up?
Please, take this thing away from me.
Its very sight troubles me to no end.
May your faith protect thee, Brother Luther, for that's all you have.
I have a feeling...
Okay, we're stomping away.
What's going on?
Oh, my gosh!
Custodian, watch out!
Paul has been given a sacrificial knife.
Wait.
If I go back, what's gonna happen?
Oh, he's gone.
Okay.
I have a feeling that if we use it, like we stick it in the statue, you know?
And it's going to kill him in real life, you know?
I don't think Custodian is a bad guy, right?
He's not a bad guy.
He's on our...
Where'd you come from?
I don't know.
Trust Master Miller.
Oh, yeah.
He is voiced by Cam Clark.
He's literally voiced by Liquid.
Oh, my gosh.
We got fresh meat.
What are you staring at?
Oh, I hate these.
Can I use this as like a weapon?
Ornate long-bladed knife.
Used to...
Used to sacrifice humans.
For Paul to even pick it up is repulsive.
For the sense of evil it emits is intense.
And unnerving.
The souls this blade has taken live on within its metal.
Sounds like I should be using it.
Try the green shield.
Oh, okay.
Shield.
So...
So, if I cast a spell upon myself...
Am I casting it...
of the same thing that the creature is?
So, it would be green to green?
Like, I'm casting a spell of green against green?
Is that how it works?
For the shield, at least?
Or do I do the opposite?
I cannot tell.
Green message for green woman.
Shield protects the same color...
bar.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Thank you.
That's all I need to know.
Bar, bar.
Yeah!
Get it, Paul!
Get him, Paul!
Yeah!
The way he just like...
Flails his arm, his whole body out.
Now I'm officially a geriatric.
Happy birthday, Gilnick!
Oh, wait.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Gilnick.
You're very old.
No, I'm just kidding.
You're still young.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
Um...
Okay.
Yes, we're going back into the basement.
Who's in here?
Anybody?
Anyone?
Anybody in here?
Anybody?
Anybody in?
I hear something.
Maybe I don't.
Um...
Let's go down.
So now we take the stairs.
We take the knife to that statue we saw earlier, right?
The one...
That has the little slot in it.
The one that yearns for the knife.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, look.
We have just like one little swirly now.
Oh, I see how it works.
So it was like...
It was three.
Now it's...
Or it was five.
Before...
The other shield was three.
I see how it works.
Just one little guy left.
Actually...
How do I sneak again?
Sorry.
I'm going to check the controller.
Uh...
Sneak is X.
Okay.
X.
Yes.
That's better.
Thanks.
Thanks for the 20 gifted.
I feel like...
You know...
It's just easier probably to handle them like that.
Okay.
Alright.
To the statue.
Which is...
Ouch.
Hayden!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
We're still okay.
Alright.
Dissolve.
What is your aim?
Um...
It's not me.
It's...
It's Paul.
You're insulting an old man right now.
He needs glasses.
Okay?
It's not his fault.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
But this is the room we need to be in.
Do I...
Enchant?
Yeah.
We can...
Enchant.
Oh wait.
It would be...
Fire.
Oh I guess I could have done purple.
I'm so stupid.
Whatever.
It's fine.
Holy... Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, we obliterated him!
We obliterated him!
That's crazy!
Oh, direct counter is stronger.
Okay, okay, okay.
Dang.
Okay!
Custodian!
I must sacrifice my friend!
Are
you okay?
The monk in the effigy has been sacrificed!
A dagger protrudes from a deep groove within his chest.
The echoes of his scream still reverberate in Paul's ears.
Do you guys think he's okay?
Oops.
It's like...
What is this?
Paul's progress forward is blocked by a corrosive spell.
Obviously someone wants to keep intruders at bay.
And this lethal magic is just a way to do it.
I have a spell for that!
Dispel magic!
But I think I need a five one, so let's...
Check.
Um...
Nethlek Redgormor.
Okay.
Um...
Reth...lek...
Reth...
Wait.
Is it one of the question mark ones?
Uh-oh.
Redgormor?
He's red?
Well, it's fine.
As long as I learn it, I can still...
Is it this one?
Let's try it.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no!
It doesn't matter which one I learn, you guys.
Because it's still...
Oh, there we go.
Um...
I can still use it.
Dispel magic.
Cast.
Red.
Watcha doing out here.
Uh-oh.
What a pain in the ass.
Ah...
All good.
And I'll continue.
So there shouldn't be anything else.
I mean...
That spell was so hard to get through.
They wouldn't need any other protective measures.
You know?
But that's a person.
Ahhhh!
Lying in a pool of his own blood is the Custodian, Paul's only ally in his fight against the darkness.
His soul no doubt lingers, fused to the altar on which his life has been taken.
Watching over his own rapidly cooling corpse.
Feeling all hope escape him, Paul's situation is suddenly a thousand times more desperate than before.
Now he is alone, alone against the darkness.
You are a clever man, Brother Luther.
Wanting answers to clarify your new position as fugitive.
You seek them out, and this is what you find.
Tell me, what does a man such as yourself think?
When he finds a viper's nest of heresy.
When he finds the very source of corruption.
I think of irony.
Irony of what you, masquerading as a member of the Inquisition, stand for.
And that you stand for evil.
Evil is merely a perspective which no longer concerns me, Luther.
You will be executed in the most painful manner imaginable.
How does anyone look at this guy and think he's okay?
After you have broken your frail body.
And mine.
No, don't mind break me.
In the name of our true Lord.
Xelaton!
Come, my children.
Uh oh.
Feast on this morsel.
Uh oh, wait.
And let us return to our preparation.
Oh wait, no.
Don't do that.
Ew.
Oh.
We have to send in the worst ones.
Oh, okay.
They're just...
Oh, why do you have to send in the worst guys?
I hate these guys.
Oh, our thing is still...
Uh, hopefully it stays, um...
What's the word?
Enchanted?
Ow!
No, no, no!
Oh.
Finish him!
Ow!
Oh my god, again?
Get off of me!
I can not reach...
Oh!
Oh, we got him, we got him.
Finish him!
Yeah, take that.
Oh, Custodian, I'm so sorry.
I knew it was going to happen.
I still did it.
It's my fault.
It's okay, I'll get revenge.
Can I save in here?
I know I just saved, but... you know me.
I'm a save queen.
Yeah, now what?
I actually feel like that should have been the end of the chapter.
But now I'm just like...
So we... our friend that was going to help us is gone.
And...
Oh, there's this door!
Of course.
Oh, my sassy.
We just go on in there.
I'm following with you!
Friendly right behind you!
He's fast.
What did you do?
Run in there?
What's the rush?
What's the hurry?
Where did he go?
Okay.
Why do these look like the hallways of like the...
Those look like the stairs and then the hallways of like the ancient temple.
Oh!
That's a mysterious door.
This door is decorated more than most within the catacombs.
Sensing an immense evil behind this door, Paul wonders if the ceremony the monk had mentioned earlier is taking place behind it.
Should Paul enter and put an end to the heresy?
Okay.
Yes, but...
In like two seconds.
Okay, hold on, Paul.
Hold on, Paul.
We got some...
We have some things...
Some matters to handle first.
Yeah!
Nobody heard that from inside the room.
Also, it was so loud.
Hold on.
I'm so sorry.
I turned it up a little bit because the audio was a little loud.
I mean, a little low and then...
The audio balancing in this game is...
A little less than it would be desired, but you know.
Actually, I am gonna save.
And see.
And then just go in.
And if I die, which I probably will...
I can just see what I need to like enchant and stuff.
Once I'm done.
You know?
Whoa!
Kingdom Hearts!
Oh, that's...
Oh, that...
Paul...
If your name is Paul, you're so lucky right now.
I forgot.
If your name is Luther right now, you're so lucky.
I forgot that there's this big thing in here that we're gonna have to fight.
Okay, so this is...
Going to be a battle.
Okay, so this is a...
This is quite a battle, isn't it?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Shout out to all the Pauls today.
One
that seeks to do combat with me.
Ooh!
Your task, my liege and greater guardian, is to guard this place.
Do not worry about this worm.
Worm?
Oh!
It is my yelps in terror at the sight of your mightiness.
We will dispose of you.
We will give him our souls.
Uh-oh!
Oh my god, no!
Oh!
If I am to guard this place, then I will do it as I see fit.
Be gone.
Leave me.
And I will guard this artifact as you have instructed.
Paul!
Wait!
That's it?
Oh my gosh!
So I don't have to...
Oh...
Paul...
Oh my god!
So that's probably going to be the big baddie boss, huh?
Maybe.
At least one of them.
We found a note from Edward.
I was going in so prepared to fight, Subset!
That's so funny.
Oh my god!
What does our note from Edward say?
The note reads, My dearest Alex, I'm glad that you have followed my paper trail thus far.
I knew I could depend on you.
This will be the hardest part of your journey.
Look for the 88 keys to continue your journey into the past.
Your loving grandfather, Edward.
Are they on like a key ring?
Are they all...
Are they...
Grandpa, you're leaving out some really crucial information here.
Are they all in one spot?
Like...
Grandpa, you're...
Oh my gosh, my sanity is so low.
Oh, let me save too.
Oh, goodbye Paul.
Alright, um...
I want to find this.
Um...
Wow.
The way her hips move is so awesome.
I don't think I ever noticed before.
Minto's mind was blown when the boss fake out.
Kind of like Paul's.
You will find his keys in one piece.
Oh...
The keys.
Geez.
Are they in this?
Is it this?
Okay, what new stuff did we... have we...
What new spells have we learned?
Five star.
Enchant item, recover.
Reveal invisible.
Yeah, we got Paragon.
Summon trapper.
This one is summon zombie.
This one is mystery.
I don't remember what this one is.
Shield.
Damage field.
What do I
have to do with this thing?
Nothing moves.
I think I need that... another piece before I can do this.
Maybe.
I can't tell.
Wasn't there someone else without a head?
What are these pieces on the ground?
Pick up?
Oh!
Ammunition!
Uh oh.
This can't be happening!
I was gonna say, uh oh.
If I need ammunition, that means I'm fighting.
What is this?
Grandpa!
Grandpa, quit using the fireplace!
Grandpa really likes the...
Oh gosh!
I got 99 problems and 88 more keys.
My sanity is still low and I'm getting scary things.
It's freaking me out.
88 keys.
It's not upstairs or...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Then you have these doors.
Let's check them out.
Uh...
It's been a while since I've looked in here.
So...
Okay.
There was like the phone and everything.
Yeah.
Um...
Here's one key.
Oh!
It's too dark.
The circuit.
Oh...
Circuit?
Where would the circuit be?
Okay.
I don't think it's over there.
We already thought.
Are there trash?
Are people trying to spoil?
It's okay.
I might ask for a hint later.
Oh yeah.
Our sanity is low.
Okay.
Oh!
I remember the sanity of the thing in this one with the bathroom.
It freaked me out.
Um...
You're okay.
Kind of giving it out.
What?
The answer?
Or the keys?
Because everyone's giving me...
I've gotten like three keys now from people in chat.
We're so close.
Um...
Okay.
What?
Do I need to do the circuit downstairs?
Why do they always knock on the doors that I'm going to?
I think we should use the...
What's that sound?
You guys are blocking it but...
Do you see him in the corner?
Oh my god!
That scared the hell out of me.
Ah!
The darkness.
He's here.
That scared me.
Look at her just looking up like, that was weird.
Oh yeah,
because he played the organ.
Her hands are drawn to the keys.
Oh, almost of their own accord.
Should Alex play the piano?
We're playing the...
the same song!
Was
that a monkey?
Piano keys!
I should have played...
I should have played Undertale.
Sans Undertale instead.
Chapter page!
Alex has found a chapter page entitled...
The Forbidden City!
Oh,
we're back!
Oh my gosh.
Who are you?
I am your lord and conqueror.
What manner of forsaken being are you?
So...
you can see me in my true form.
You are a gifted man.
Take this one...
and use him as the foundation for the pillar.
He is special.
He is special?
And you will be given a special place...
among the suffering.
Okay.
Not the pillar.
Oh god, right, the pillar.
Uh-oh.
Is next chapter...
kind of special?
Is next chapter something...
I should be really looking forward to?
No, no, no.
The pillar.
It's gonna be pillar man.
It's great.
IMO?
Okay.
I'll believe you.
But I will save that for...
next...
week!
I'm so sorry.
I was so sleepy today, you guys.
I was so sleepy.
How many... Wait, so that was... Oh, we got through two chapters.
No, sorry.
Yes.
Two chapters.
We... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got through two chapters.
So, how many more is that after?
Like three or four chapters?
Next chapter is kind of slow and tedious.
Okay.
I'll do my best.
Maybe we'll see Mint use the Icemon key in the next Blued stream.
The Icemon... Icemon key.
Three left, I think.
I can't... I'll have to check.
Thanks, Dry Princess!
Great job getting past two long chapters.
Have a great rest.
Paragon, paragon.
You'll probably finish next stream.
Don't worry.
Yeah, we'll see.
We'll see.
Five.
Wait, I think...
I can't remember how many chapters I'm on.
I wish I would...
Wait, does it say in the menu?
Ooh, who's running around?
Kind of freaky.
Oh, that's a lamp.
Never mind.
Just says chapter page.
Check.
Just says chapter... Yeah.
Doesn't say.
Thanks for being... Thanks for the awesome stream.
Mint, been great watching you play this.
Thank you!
I'm having so much fun.
This...
This story is so fascinating.
The gameplay is so...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the sanity effects?
Get me every time still.
Like, most of them at least.
They're so crazy.
Like the... What was the one?
The...
There was one that really got me.
I can't remember earlier, but yeah.
Thank you for the stream.
I had a blast watching you live tonight.
Rest well and see you soon.
Thank you, Tanuki!
You still haven't seen the worst one?
The blue screen was great.
The blue screen was really funny.
Especially because I'm playing it on my computer.
So feels more like I'm actually getting a blue screen.
The flies?
The flies that were on my computer screen?
were really cool.
Yeah, I'm going to try and keep my sanity lower.
So that I can, like, experience more freaky things.
And if not, maybe I'll like... look up a...
Eternal dark...
Like once I'm done with the game.
I'll look up an Eternal Darkness Sanity Effects video, if one of those exists.
I was like, what is making all that noise?
It's the page, it's the chapter, it's so noisy.
Thanks for the early stream today!
Any stream plans for tomorrow?
Oh yes!
I do have stream plans for tomorrow.
I believe I'm streaming all this coming week, every day.
And so, I will...
Sorry, I'm checking my phone real quick.
I will have a schedule up tonight, hopefully.
As long as I don't fall asleep.
And if not, I'll have it up tomorrow morning.
You must have missed it.
Was afraid to ask if this was the demo.
Demo of the game?
No, no.
I'm quite far into the game, I think.
But yeah, I want to finish this up before I go to Japan.
So hopefully, you know, next week.
Hopefully in one more stream.
If you guys think maybe one more stream.
If not, we'll see.
Every day, hopefully you don't get burnt out.
No, no, I feel good.
And because I'm going to Japan next week too, I want to make sure I stream every day since I'll be gone for a couple of days.
Yeah, yeah.
No, next weekend more Eternal Darkness and Metal Gear Solid 3.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got to play as much of Metal Gear Solid 3 before TGS.
So I can have a very good impression of like, Oh, this was different.
This was the same.
This felt different.
This was different.
This was the same.
You know, I have to give a very accurate report.
My book report.
My game report.
But I have some other stuff.
I have fun stuff.
I am, I think, in a collab this coming week as well.
I believe on Tuesday.
With a bunch of people.
Some people that I've never collabed with before.
So I'm excited about that.
And...
So I'm in a collab.
Doing Pico Park 2.
And I have been putting together some other fun collab stuff.
For once I'm back as well.
So... and then of course my birthday.
And... yeah.
My birthday.
I have an announcement on my birthday.
So I think you guys might want to come.
If you hadn't already thought about it.
But it's also going to be a fun stream.
I think.
Because I'm cooking a little bit.
And... yeah.
And I'm very excited.
Yeah.
Leafly October 5th.
I know.
There's so much going on.
So much happening.
So...
I know.
I think part of the reason why I haven't been sleeping very well is...
I'll like go to take a nap.
And then my mind will...
You know like when you take a shower.
And you get like all your good ideas in the shower.
It's kind of like that for me.
But I'm like about to fall asleep.
And I'm like oh my god.
I just had an idea.
And I like have to get on my phone and write it down.
So...
To me my mind has just been racing and racing and racing at what...
At what all I can do.
And stuff that I've been trying to plan.
And hopefully it all works out.
And it all works good.
But...
Yeah.
Hopefully.
It's a bit of a lot.
As in my one man army.
But...
I'm excited.
I'm excited to finish this game.
Excited for...
Hold on.
Sorry.
I just sneezed too.
Stop.
You are Minto.
Sorry.
I sneezed like an old man.
I don't have like a cute sneeze.
I sneeze like an old man.
I'm like...
Yeah.
So...
Okay.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today.
And...
I'm so glad that we can play more Eternal Darkness.
Again, I'm so sorry.
It took me so long to get back to this.
But...
I'm glad to be back in.
I'm really...
I...
You know...
The first time I was like so confused that I was like what's going on to be kind of invested.
But now I'm like really...
I feel really, really in.
So I'm like...
Okay.
I'm...
Excited to see how the ending is.
How this turns out.
How...
We escape the darkness.
And how we make it non-existent.
Not eternal.
Only...
Like...
Maybe like a...
Bi-annual darkness.
You know?
You're an old man for other reasons but you sneeze like a pure maiden.
Huh?
What other ways?
I'm Oji-san.
I'm just like...
You know...
I really...
Connect with Hoshino from Blue Archive when she called herself Oji-san.
And I'm just like...
Yeah.
And...
Yeah, me too.
Okay!
Thank you guys...
For hanging out.
I will see you guys...
Tomorrow.
And if I don't see you tomorrow, I'll see you whenever I can see you.
And...
Thank you guys so much.
Paragon!
Aso-minto-gon!
Aso-minto!
Bye-bye!
Thank you!
Bye -bye!
Bye-bye!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community